under donald trump
he had an executive order that banned
effectively critical race theory
trainings
at uh in the government as well as any
company that implemented these trainings
as well well when joe biden got in
he rescinded this executive order and
now there are questions about what's
going to be happening at universities
apparently there was a rule from the
department of education that
racial affinity groups were
discriminatory these
groups are basically when they take a
bunch of people of one race and
make them segregate under donald trump
that was against the rules and now under
joe biden it is
within the rules and in my opinion
shockingly
discriminatory well we have a very
specific story
uh from smith college and one of their
staff members who was a white staff
member
who is accusing the university of
anti-white racism
but instead of me trying to break down
the the long and
arduous journey for you we actually are
joined by jody shaw who
you were the staffer who resigned you
want to introduce yourself yes i am hi
i'm jody shaw
former staffer of smith college uh
should i tell the story just really just
a real quick and simple introduction
like you quit for
you know oh uh well like 30 seconds okay
so uh
there's a lot of context but essentially
smith uh's various initiatives and
policies
aimed at achieving racial justice are
grounded in critical race theory
and what we know about critical race
theory is not
um it's not that somebody commits an act
of racism it's that
somebody is racist simply based on their
skin color
and that skin color happens to be white
basically
wokeness is taking over these
universities and you have to experience
it firsthand
and it essentially forced you out so
we'll talk about your story
and there's a bunch of other stories
apparently there's another professor
who's come out
and you know called it what do you call
it like a religion basically a
non-secular religion
secular religion secular religion right
psychology which is uh
we heard that from peter bergogen and
james lindsey and helen pluck rose as
well
years ago so we'll get into this we're
also hanging out with ian hey everyone
ian crossland up in this how's it going
yeah up in this house there you go
yes hello and also me in the corner
pushing buttons i'm sarah patch lynch
before we get started we have an amazing
sponsor today virtual shield a virtual
private network service go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and you can get
a virtual private network service
50 off for life that's 2.50
per month you may be asking tim what is
a virtual private network service it is
a basic layer of security for you as you
browse the internet
there are nefarious actors there's
governments there's corporations they
want to steal your data they want to spy
on you
they want to collect information about
you they want to know things about you
that you yourself probably don't know
they can predict your behavior it's
really really creepy stuff
if you would like a basic layer of
security make it harder for these
nefarious actors to collect your
information
go to surfinginternetsafe.com get
virtual shield again basic layer of
security here's the way
i describe it we don't expect people to
break into our houses
we still lock our doors and windows
because hey it might happen we at least
want to make it a little bit harder for
those who might do it
and in the event you end up a target of
maybe somebody wants to steal your
credit card information or intrude on
you or spy on your browser history or
something like that
you'll probably want a vpn and it's not
that hard to set up just go to surfing
internet safe
and you can get again 50 off for life
it's the link is in the description
below
and i just want to shout out virtual
shield they're my first sponsor they've
been here
for you know with me for years and they
really help make all this possible so
if you want to return the favor again
surfing internetsafe.com
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member
to get access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast we
have a bunch of really fun and silly
uh segments and i got guys for some
reason don't ask me why
all of these segments end up turning
into conversations about dmt and god
for some reason it's like hey we're
gonna talk about aliens well
interestingly dmt and god and then we
have you know kurt schlichter talking
about dr fauci and then it all just
finds its way in there because
we just reduced all these conversations
to the bigger questions i guess but
anyway
if you like the idea of these
conversations go to timcast.com become a
member
click the like button share subscribe
all that stuff leave us a good review if
you're listening on itunes or spotify
because that really really does help
five stars
and again share this podcast if you
really like it today is going to be much
more focused on
a lot of topical stories but we're going
to jump into
the story from jody so we can better
understand exactly what's going on
with your case and what you're
experiencing these universities so all
laid out i think most
people understand wokeness critical
theory which is not just race theory
it's also critical gender theory
there's they seem to be formless in a
sense like the rules don't really make
sense
they just want you to bend the knee and
adhere to their strange subjective
reality
it's resulting in overtly bigoted and
racist policies which in my opinion
violate the 1964 civil rights act so for
me personally
one of the reasons i supported trump in
this election cycle this past election
cycle
was because of his because of his
executive order banning critical race
theory
in the government as well as contracts
with companies that do this
because i've seen firsthand what happens
when you implement
these neo-racist neo-segregationist
policies
universities are creating affinity
groups they're telling all the white
people to segregate all the black people
to segregate
and then it creates very strange
problems with whether or not asians are
minorities or they're white and
privileged
so you've experienced this first hand
and first
just tell me the story and and whatever
detail you want to tell us a story
where you ultimately resigned from your
job because i guess they were being
racist to you for being white
yes that's accurate all right thank you
for telling your story
what happened where did you work smith
college what's going on smith college so
uh
i started off at smith as a temporary
librarian working in the library as an
outreach and engagement librarian and i
was hired
to do you know kind of out-of-the-box
things to engage
students who otherwise normally wouldn't
engage very deeply with the library
and um about
i don't know almost a year after i was
hired i was or six months after i was
hired i was tasked with a
doing a wild and crazy event for 600
first-year students
and uh i decided and i was given a big
venue
and the people who gave me the venue
said we will give you this venue
if you do something wild and crazy
because these kids are going to be
exhausted this is the sixth day of the
event
um so you got to agree to that so i did
and i thought
and i'm i have a musician background so
i thought well what's the best way to
transmit a bunch of very boring
information to a bunch of 6 600
first-year students obviously a wrap so
everyone knew i was going to be doing a
wrap i spent months
preparing working with musicians getting
everything set up the sound and
everything and
simultaneously i was up for a permanent
job at smith college
so i worked all summer on this and then
something happened at smith
on july 31st 2018
a student a black student accused a
white
custodian of engaging in racially
motivated behavior
against her she was in a house that she
was not supposed to be in it was over
the summer
and the staff there had allowed her to
be in the house but this custodian
didn't know who she was she was lying
down in this living room couldn't see
her very well and this document this
incident's been documented quite well
now in a recent new york
times article ever since that incident
um
the college immediately so the student
that was like two years ago wasn't it
yeah this is in 2018
july she made a facebook post so she
didn't even file a formal complaint
she simply posted about the experience
on facebook and said that this was a
just another example of a pattern of
systemic racism she had experienced at
smith college
so smith the college immediately sprung
into action
announcing profuse apologies to the
student and to the student body
and announced its intention to launch
all these initiatives and
committees and conversations and discuss
dialogues
to combat this issue of systemic racism
at the college and this was before
they'd even
conducted any investigation into what
had actually happened that day
so they did conduct an investigation a
very thorough one
and they found that there was absolutely
no evidence of racial bias
and anyone who has is privy to the facts
of what happened that day and has read
this investigatory report which is
it's 35 pages plus 130 pages of exhibits
i mean it was really thorough
they would be hard-pressed to argue that
this was an incident of racial bias
that in and of itself is insane that a
woman was sitting down in some
she was in a closed dorm a janitor saw
her and said who's this
so instead of confronting the person
which could have been a bad call he
called a cop
the cop was very polite this video of it
where he's just like how's it going
how are things sorry for bothering you
and that warranted an independent
investigatory body coming in
a 35-page report 35-page report
plus exhibits floor plans audio
recordings
they they investigated phone calls to
campus this is campus police so unarmed
it wasn't like the town police this is
campus police a 30 a guy who'd been
working there for 35 years
his name's robert young beloved spotless
record um he showed up and he actually
i think he recognized the student i
heard he recognized her and
and and she was able to stay um
so yeah they really it was like they
were really trying hard
to almost to prove that it was in my
opinion almost to prove that it was and
and they weren't able to that
the outside investigators said this this
is not an incident of racial bias
and yet they proceeded with all these
initiatives
and it's almost like it didn't matter
what the event was they
wanted the the anti-racism which is just
a name by the way they wanted the
critical race theory
policies in the school and it sounds
like they knew it was bunk but they
needed a pretext
and even though it was proven bunk they
moved forward anyway
that's i think that's an accurate
analysis
um so so what ended up happening to you
then so what happened to me was you know
meanwhile i'm in the library working on
my rap
and um about so this happened on july
31st
and the the orientation i was doing was
happening
in very early like right after labor day
and so within a week
of me doing this huge thing organizing
an event for 600 people it's no small
undertaking i was told
my supervisor came in and said you know
you can't do this you can't do a rap
and i said why not he said because
you're white and it would be seen as
cultural appropriation
so um did you try identifying as not
white
i did ask i said i said that's kidding i
didn't i said i said so
if i was not white or i know i said if i
was a person of color and i didn't
indicate what color
i said if i was a person of color would
i be allowed to do it he said yes
without hesitation so
obviously just anybody except for
somebody's white what about eminem
did you tell him that yeah well he
didn't have
well i mean yeah people say that
macklemore and i mean of course tom
mcdonald but
i mean really rap is an american
it's an american art it's an america
it's culturally american i
i think that's my view i don't
understand why we all can't just
you know appreciate you know what i mean
like it's actually like racist of me to
try and play that game about what about
a white guy who did it too and wasn't
right it's an american art form who
invented the guitar where did the guitar
come from huh good question who's using
that or keyboards
or uh turntables who invented the record
player yeah
or the loot uh everybody everyone
that's why i'm like this stuff is really
scary because
it's it's kind of obvious let me ask you
the the
the supervisor who came and said you
can't rap is this like a middle-aged
white dude
he's a white dude but he's not
middle-aged he's younger than me and
he's actually the head of the search
committee for the job i was up for so it
was very awkward oh
was he woke like
i mean he's towing the line so coward
is it i'm you should don't don't answer
that don't answer that
uh i personally do not respect
individuals who would say something like
that because
i think what he said to you was was
extremely racist
extreme that's right it was so it was
but it was so unhesitating
i mean the manner in which he said it
and then followed up by email he
memorialized this in an email in writing
and then i went to the dean of the
libraries and i said you know
what's going on and she actually told
said to me something that was a veiled
threat remember i was up for a job and
she said well
how you choose how you manage to be
resilient in the face of this situation
is really going to give us a lot of
information
in light of your candidacy for this job
it was something like that i'm
paraphrasing
so i mean that's to me that's a failed
threat and
so the fact that they did it so
blatantly and explicitly
i was genuinely confused um i was like
because when i heard about the student
all i heard was a black student was just
lying on a couch in a house
and somebody called the police on her
that's terrible like that was the
narrative that i heard
you know i had didn't really go because
there was no investigation that's what
the college told me i really didn't have
reason not to believe them at that point
so i was confused i was like well
you know this really feels like racial
discrimination he literally told me
because i'm
because you're white you can't do this
this job opportunity
um and i wrestled with well should i
file a complaint i was like but
can white people be discriminated
against like is that possible and i
thought well gee if i if i report it
i'll never get a job here because white
people aren't supposed to
complain about this stuff they're not
supposed to do that and so it was a very
um hard
hard for me emotionally to wrestle with
what
i was supposed to do with that and what
i ended up doing was i ended up
leaving the library and moving to a
different department on campus
thinking that i could get away from
because there was also lots of
these discussions and dialogues
discussion styles that were happening
even before this
event had occurred that i just went
along with and again i had no reason to
believe oh there's systemic racism okay
and i guess you know as a white person
you're supposed to talk about
your privilege and that's going to help
somehow so i thought
okay but inside it always felt like
it felt kind of um disingenuous so
you didn't quit at this point no i left
i stayed in the school yeah it's a long
story so i went to a different
department
and i didn't know that this department
the department of residence life is
very steeped in the social justice
um that's one of its like core values
and again at the time i thought oh
social justice yeah
i'm i can get with that i hadn't quite
put all the pieces
together and i think this is part of the
problem is a lot of people are genuinely
confused
you need to be watching tim cast ireland
it's not your fault though i mean you
know don't know about how awesome i'm
kidding i'm kidding continue continue
yeah i definitely need to be watching
tim caston
[Laughter]
so uh yeah i moved into this department
and
other things started happening on campus
like the campus police officer who
showed up to that
incident was was terminated a year later
and this is a guy
for racism no it's for undisclosed
reasons wow
and he was a 35 year veteran about to
retire
spotless police right he was beloved we
called him officer bob he was there when
i was a student there
that's that's a simpsons joke where
they're like he was two days away from
retirement
like they do that all the time like the
dog gets hit by a car like ah it was two
days away from retirement
here's this cop i mean it's it's it's
kind of it it's it's
it's parody in it of itself it's like
life imitating art it's so it's so
absurd
yeah it's absurd and it's really it's
tragic um because the other thing that
happened with this student was she made
this facebook post and then she made
a sub she didn't know the name of the
custodian she couldn't identify the
custodian who had called campus police
on her so she posted the photos
and email addresses of two other
wow unrelated like people who were not
involved um
a dining room person and another
custodian he wasn't even there
he'd left to shift for the day before it
even happened and those two
the lives of those two people were i
mean
i think it was catastrophic one of them
uh
during the investigation he was put on
leave and uh a paid leave and he ended
up not coming back to the college he had
pre
some pre-existing conditions and it was
it was too much he didn't come back and
then
the dining room worker uh was harassed
i mean she got phone calls she got notes
in her home mailbox
she students would whisper and point at
her there's the racist
she recently she was then furloughed
this past summer and she applied for a
job somewhere and the
you know to to make up for the fir for
the loss of her
temporary loss of her job at smith and
the person who are hiring her said
weren't you the person
that was involved with that student when
the they called the police and she was
like
no no she tried to explain and she
didn't get the job i mean we can't know
for sure that well if
she didn't get the job for that reason
but i would say yes but i
what you need to understand once the
word gets out
you'll hear this look i understand you
weren't at fault but i mean
we we can't have those people coming
after us so i'm just sorry you
understand right
yeah that's the thing once you're out
there you are unhireable
and it's not when it's not about whether
they believe you or not it's that they
don't want you near
there so now so so now you're waking up
to the realities that are
the the cult of you know wokeness
but you still work at the college i
still work at the college i'm starting
to wake up i'm starting to like pay
attention more
some other things start happening around
campus i feel like i'm walking on
eggshells
i'm trying you know i took a lower
paying position
as um uh in admit doing administrative
support so i was no longer a teaching
librarian i was kind of like i thought
oh i can hide down here
that's kind of what i thought very nuts
and bolts like getting students their
id's getting them keys
very very like salt like practical kind
of job
and yet you know i was told i had to
attend
uh staff meetings where people were
talking about identity
um we talked we had there was one staff
meeting where we talked about
the cl how colonialism
was it white supremacy
like examples of how white supremacy
still manifests at the college
and one of my colleagues um started
banging on the table saying rich white
women rich white women and
he was talking about the alums he's
talking about the alums
and so nobody batted an eyelash you know
i'm like this
feels very like i mean this doesn't feel
professional
there there was no like did they start
bang bang on the table and chanting
google gobble one of us
at you trying to convince you to join
the cult didn't happen
anybody who gets that reference you
deserve something a president what is it
i don't actually it's from uh
thank you it's from the movie called
freaks i think i think it's called
freaks
and there's this beautiful woman she's
trying to marry this freak who's got an
inheritance
and so all the freaks at the table are
chanting google gobble one of us but
she's not a freak and so she's like no
and she like runs away screaming yeah
that was me
i'm that woman so but but is that was
that is that how you ended up quitting
or
no so then like you know i started
gently i felt gently talking to my
supervisors like
because the other thing they were asking
me to do was to support a curriculum for
students
that was essentially telling students
that you can break the world down into
two groups of people
oppressed and oppressors
and oppressors are white and everyone
else is oppressed and
i felt like that was really such a
disservice to students it made me very
uncomfortable it felt like
the infantilization i was talking to
lydia about earlier of
of students like telling students of
color like you can't quite handle the
world and
um until until your white counterparts
start talking about their white
privilege
nothing's going to happen for you it's
kind of this toxic dependency
thing and i i just felt like it was
incredibly disempowering to both
white students and non-white students
and so i tried to raise this several
times with my supervisor
nothing happened i finally just was like
i'm not
i don't want to talk about my race at
work i started thinking gee you know you
can't ask about race in a job interview
so how is it that this is a continued
condition of my employment
um so i was told we were going to go
this is the big event we're going to go
to
a professional development retreat on
campus and the first day we would be
discussing our identities
so i went to my supervisor and i said
you know and i knew that meant race
because that's usually what it means and
i said you know i'm uncomfortable
discussing my race at work
and she said no problem just say that at
the
retreat so i thought okay so i went to
the retreat and everyone went around the
table and we did the script
talking about our race and it was
actually they wanted us to talk about
our race in the context of our childhood
no less race culture they were like
conflating the two
and so i said i'm uncomfortable talking
about this at work
and then a little later one of the hired
facilitators said
i was the only one to abstain by the way
one of the hired facilitators said
you know any white person who
declines or exhibits discomfort which i
had
in discussing their race when requested
is not actually uncomfortable you might
want to
you might want to feel like you empathy
for them but don't they're actually
doing it what they're doing is a power
play
and it's called white fragility and so
they said this and my
my heart just dropped because this was
in front of all my colleagues
and that's when a line was crossed for
me
because i realized this wasn't just i
couldn't just keep you can't just keep
your head down and mouth shut in this
environment
this is an environment in which now
shame and public humiliation
is being used as a tool to compel
certain behavior because they wanted me
to talk about my race and i
they wanted me to talk about in a
certain way
i answered the question authentically
which is i am uncomfortable
discussing my race and that was not an
acceptable response
so at that point i knew i had to file a
complaint
which brings me to filing the complaint
with the officer in charge of making
sure smith follow
complies with eeoc which is the equal
employment opportunity commission
laws she has a jd and when i went to
file my complaint
i met with her and she looked at me she
was rather incredulous
and she said do you believe in white
privilege
and i was like what and then she said
you know the civil rights act of 1964
was created to protect
traditionally marginalized groups of
people so i interpret that to mean not
me
and then the last thing she said was
you know i'm going to have to hire an
outside investigator to
to deal with this if you're going to
proceed with filing a complaint of
racial discrimination and harassment
and i said well why is that aren't you
the person that processes these
complaints and she said yes but
this is different because you're white
she literally said those words she
literally said those words she said
that twice two two different occasions
and
i followed them up with emails of course
because by now i'm being very careful
about paper trail and everything
so when so i i filed the complaint
and i filed it i think it was probably
like a week before george floyd was
murdered
and so smith
smith went into hyper drive after the
july 31st 2018 incident with the
combating systemic racism stuff and the
all the initiatives they went into super
duper hyperdrive after george floyd
and and remember this time like we're in
a global pandemic
nobody knows what's going on suddenly
everybody's like the college is closed
everyone's working from home we're going
to furlough all these people
everyone's worried about their job and
the college comes out with this
four-page document called toward racial
justice smith outlining
further initiatives including
initiatives aimed at measuring
uh pay across registers of identity so
we're talking about like you now it's
being tied to your job performance
so at that point i started sending
emails to hr and other people asking you
know can you give me definitions
of this stuff like what do you mean by
equity and what does this mean because
now you're telling me this is tied to my
pay
and they there was
nothing happening i i in the meantime i
was getting invited to
white staff only meetings
and being told that letters from the
president saying white people are
especially responsible for combating
racism and doing this work
and we all have to work and do this hard
work and it felt like
it was just constant constant emails and
constantly
talking about what being white and um
how responsible white people are for all
this racism and how horrible
the systemic racism is and um
and how i need to do all this work
and by now it's been made clear to me
that it's not optional right i mean they
say well you know it's optional but if i
don't go
i've been you know it's like clearly
that could be interpreted as an act of
aggression or a power play
so um cut to october i
finally decided that um i was in a bad
state
psychologically and um and physically
and i decided that my
my health was the damage that that i was
causing to myself by remaining in this
environment was
uh worse than what might happen if i
made a video about it
so i made a youtube video and that
actually kind of just
blew up i didn't know what would happen
did you quit at this point
no you really want to get to the part
where i quit
no yeah kind of i guess but no not
really i'm just curious if like
you know it sounds like i'll put it this
way it really does sound like you
you were constantly being pushed to your
breaking point and from what you're
telling me you're like
they told me i had to say this and i'm
like wow surely that made you quit
but hearing that each and every beat in
the story you're like you stayed
through it i tried yeah because i i was
going through all the internal channels
of
trying i i had i was a good faith effort
on my part i thought well
surely if i show them that this is wrong
surely they will be like oh maybe we
should review our policies or oh
gee this is hurting a staff member is
coming us telling us this is hostile and
she's being hurt like
surely we should listen to this person i
i just have i have
i no longer have faith in smith college
but i i still had some faith at the time
that perhaps
and i also knew i should i needed to
exhaust my internal
remedies too um so i made some videos
and i got put under investigation like
within a month
for an unrelated thing and
um then i was they found me not guilty
of whatever it was i was under
investigation for a slap on the wrist
do you know what the investigation was
for yeah um we had received after i made
the video we received
a bunch of emails to my department the
departmental email which i respond to a
bunch of people respond to it and it was
like you know
uh jody shaw's the white supremacist she
went on tucker because i want to talk to
carlson after i made the video
um she's associated with the white
supremacist
therefore you should fire her and so i
was forwarding these emails to my
personal account because i'm documenting
everything by now and um
they said one of one of those emails
contained student information
i'm not clear on what they didn't tell
me which email was
um and i wasn't able to determine which
email they meant
but it was a slapped on the wrist and
then it was like
okay you can come back to work and i i
it felt like that was a hard choice um
whether or not to go back or um
i'm not going to talk about the there
were some
settlement negotiations which i won't
get into but um
i it felt like going back into an
abusive relationship
and i thought i wouldn't go back into an
abusive relationship
so i can't i can't go back and that's
when i resigned
i can't believe you made it that far i
can't either but you know i i
i absolutely can empathize when i worked
for fusion
they had an event where they they had
all of their you know
stars their personalities hosting
a specific event except for one person
and uh well i should say
i'm not going to pretend like i deserve
to be a part of all of the big
productions from this disney corporate
this disney corporate you know cable
channel
but i did question why it was they
brought in an outside personality who
was black to be involved in an event
when i was actually on staff under
contract to be one of their hosts
and i don't care about the race of the
individual my question was why hire
someone from the outside if you're
paying me to do this
and i was told explicitly by the
president it's because you are white
and i said don't you know that i am not
and he says you look too white and i
said i come from
you know everybody knows this by now
especially people who watch the show
second generation mixed race family
and he was like i get it man the
company's racist he told me that
and you know what i did try to quit but
i never filed a complaint
hindsight being 20 20 i wonder if i
really should have if i should have gone
because
maybe if you know at the time i didn't
really think anything of it
but you mentioned something really
interesting early on when you said that
you know you as as a white person you
had this idea that like you don't
complain about these things
when they when they criticize you or
they or they you know negatively impact
your life based on you being white or
whatever
white people don't complain and it was
interesting for me
because i didn't look at i've never i've
never had like a white racial history or
identity or anything like that because i
grew up in a mixed race area with with a
bunch of different kinds of different
races
and i had a mom who who made bulgogi for
dinner
but when i heard this i had a more
libertarian gut reaction of
you do you i'll do me break my contract
they refuse to do it
they told me you're under contract for
another year why don't we just wait
things out and see how it goes
and so in the meantime i was getting
paid well and i didn't have any
obligations with the company they told
me just do whatever because they didn't
want the problems i guess
the company wasn't always what they
decided to get woke and then
you know i wonder now if i had just been
more aware of what was going on this is
back in i think 2015
maybe i could have you know filed a
complaint that could have preempted
something like what you went through
maybe if we were all in this a little
earlier and aware of what was going on
but it didn't mean anything to me it was
just a one-off event in my life
i didn't realize at the time we had seen
you know we're seeing gamergate right
this the start of this culture war
now we can see how bad it's really
gotten so so tell me now so you ended up
resigning
and you ended up raising what like 300
grand yeah
yeah so go for it what's that all about
what's
what's what's going on what's this money
for you're going to buy a you're going
to buy a jeep
lamborghini yeah no well the money is
for
i mean anything
it's the gofundme is complicated but um
the gofundme was started because i was
quitting my job and i wasn't going to
have income
and i'm going up against an extremely
powerful institution that has a 2
billion
endowment and has hired a very expensive
attorney
and
yeah that's what the money's for and and
actually it my goal was 150
and anything over 150 actually is going
into a fund i'm working out the details
now for other people who are
in similar situations um and then i cut
that off
at 290 so now it's going back to me
because i realize now how
little 150 actually is um in spite of
what people think it's actually not that
that's not a lot it's not that much
money especially
um since this is my job now and uh
there are a lot of there's a lot of
stuff going on there's a lot of
organizing
you know in in this in the background
and a lot of work and
it's not that much money you need a
million bucks and i'm not i'm not
exaggerating and people need to realize
this
listen up everybody lawsuits are
expensive
okay and especially you're going up
against this university or is it college
college yeah they're going to have
tremendous resources
and each and every one of these woke
individuals
can put money towards this university if
they want to
the university itself has more resources
than an individual these lawsuits when
it comes to defamation going up going up
against the establishment
you're going to spend a quarter million
dollars in a couple months a couple
months
you look at just a simple defamation
case it was uh carl benjamin and akilah
hughes and i think that cost
carl somewhere around like 120 grand
if that i'm not sure maybe the number
wrong court fees alone was like forty
thousand dollars
then he had his legal fees his lawyer
fees and that's just
two individuals going over one small
defamation case you're talking about
you know you you filed an eeoc complaint
for racial discrimination
yes and so i'll i'll i'll ask a couple
questions are you
are you are are you allowed to talk
about this are you gonna be filing a
suit
privately outside of the eeoc uh that
remains to be seen
the eeoc is the first step that it's a
requirement though yeah
so and then if so i assume
when you filed your complaint you
provided testimony a sworn affidavit
no not yet that doesn't happen with the
eeoc okay um
that would that would happen if i file a
civil suit
though what is the deputy good question
ee awk it's the equal employment or
equal employment opportunity commission
yes it's like a government agency
it is and they have a state level and a
federal level and i believe in
massachusetts where i am it gets
cross-filed with the federal
government so that that is the first
step and so right now i did file the
complaint
and smith college has a certain
time limit to respond so we we get to
see how they're going to
defend we get to get a little insight
into how they might defend themselves
against these claims so you file the
complaint first
is the eeoc going assuming they take
your case did
have they or do we know that yet or what
uh well we're waiting for
they have to wait for the response yeah
a response from smith and then i think
i'm not a lawyer i think they can choose
to investigate it
if they decide it's has merit or i don't
know what their criteria is
but either way i think i can you can get
a right to sue letter
you can sue in state court or in federal
the federal level
there's a different waiting period for
each and i think you can do that
regardless of whether or not the eeoc
decides to investigate but i'm not i'm
not exactly sure about that
i'm worried that with joe biden coming
in
and you know the rule changes from the
department of education that they're
going to tell you to buzz off
yeah uh you know there's there's another
administrative agency called the office
of civil rights the ocr
and i just heard a story recently about
a woman who was having similar
similar situation she's white and so she
filed a complaint with the ocr
and the ocr this was during trump and
the ocr determined that this is a
hostile word i forget exactly what it
was but they they said yeah this is
wrong whatever is going on in this
workplace is wrong and they issued a
letter to the employer and they said
here's here are the steps you need to do
to
correct the situation it wasn't even
like she was get i don't think she was
doing from it wasn't even a lawsuit for
money or anything it was just like fix
the situation
and then um biden moved into office and
the ocr
rescinded that yep i think that was the
new york post recently
that story um so it
that is concerning i mean as you know he
rescinded trump's eo which was
essentially just
restating what's we we have so civil
rights act of 1964
just restating it really i'll tell you
what i think one of the problems is
a lot of conservatives seem to think
that donald trump needed to do all the
work
for him and not not just conservatives
conservatives had been the one paying
attention to this
more than than liberals were like you
know in the story you told you were kind
of unaware of what's going on i told a
similar story in 2014
conservatives have seen this and have
been railing at it for some
time then moderates got roped in and now
many liberals people like barry weiss
for instance are complaining about what
happened at the new york times
and you have anti-woke leftists even now
criticizing the establishment and what
they call neoliberalism
the problem is a lot of conservatives
thought donald trump was the answer
i'm not saying every single one or at
least they thought trump would be
some kind of assistance and they're not
entirely wrong
trump did come in and he did eventually
sign you know uh enact this executive
order but it took what james lindsay and
christopher ruffo
going on you know shows chris of rufo
going on tucker carlson
and saying this is a problem for trump
to enact this what in the last several
months of office
the issue is these government agencies
had been doing
absolutely racist practices in one
instance there was like i think it was
there was a certain laboratory sent all
the white people on a retreat to like
talk about
whiteness and white privilege and why
it's you know bad and things like that
we've seen many stories like that
christopher ruffo documents all of these
you know there's a bunch of examples
every single one of those people needed
to file a lawsuit
they needed to do what you are doing
right now so
what ends up happening is we have years
of this and we have many people
complaining about it but where are the
people actually
filing the suits challenging these these
institutions on
was it title seven of the 1964 civil
rights act you cannot discriminate in
the basis of race
and and gender and national origin and
things like that
when i saw donald trump was enacting
this executive order i thought to myself
he shouldn't have to do this it's
already illegal
it's interesting we had a leftist on
this show
who argued that trump was banning you
know free speech and that it was wrong
to do this and i'm like
it's already illegal to do these
programs you cannot take a bunch of
white people off to a retreat and tell
them white people are bad
that violates the law the law says race
the law doesn't say marginalized groups
you can argue the spirit or the intent
but it doesn't matter
we have these laws for a reason joe
biden has come in
we're sending the executive order and it
doesn't change the fact it's still
illegal
that means every single person who works
in the government works in these
universities or is affected by the
wokeness
needs to be filing a lawsuit today
against these institutions for what
they're doing
why aren't they doing it well we talked
about money
that's a huge thing i mean really it's
even before that the question is why
i mean i feel like more people are
speaking out but i mean people
don't even talk about it
let alone file a lawsuit i mean that's
like a big that's a big step that's a
commitment
and litigation is difficult
um we do have some other lawsuits going
on in this country though
we have a clark versus clark v democracy
prep in nevada which is a school case
it's a k-12 charter school
the gabrielle's son is a senior
and he was uh forced i mean they said
they would give him a d-minus if he
didn't profess his
is this the biracial yes so we actually
have looks white he's like you
well that's that's that's a really
there's a really funny thing about that
uh
whether i'm white appearing or not
depends on the the race of the
individual
no joke so in my experience i've
i've i've been called hispanic more than
anything else latino
i had a guide occupy wall street refer
to me as his puerto rican brother and
i'm like bro i'm not hispanic i mean i
know like the tiny bit of spanish
because i grew up in chicago
but i was in uh anaheim and i had the
guys from telemundo walk up to me
speaking spanish just assuming
i was you know latino to a certain
extent and so
it really is in the eye of the beholder
the funny thing is
if i agree with the woke all of a sudden
they can see that i'm not white
and they sent this they say see it's
because you understand if i disagree
with them they say you're white
that's that's that's the name of the
game yeah because it's it's not really
about
skin colors it's about politics yeah
it's about whether you you are in the
cult or not so
let me jump to the story we have this
from the atlanta black star they say
black mom
sues school after she says biracial son
received failing grade in sociology
class
for refusing to confess his white
dominance
a black mom is suing her biracial son's
nevada charter school
after she claims he received a failing
grade for refusing to link aspects of
his identity to oppression and dominance
in his sociology class
gabrielle clark and her son william
clark filed a suit in u.s district court
of nevada
against public charter school democracy
prep agassi campus in vegas on december
22
alleging a violation of constitutional
free speech and due process rights
william clark claims that in that class
sociology of change taught by catherine
bass
who was named as a defendant in the suit
he was harassed
and punished for refusing to attach
derogatory labels
to aspects of his identity clark whose
deceased father was white
is generally regarded as white by his
peers according to the complaint
and has green eyes and blondish hair the
far
right advocacy group international
organization for the family
which has been attracting the case
closely reports that a u.s district
court
judge said at a february 22nd temporary
restraining order hearing
i think william is likely to succeed on
the merits of his compelled speech
claims
saying that the defendants will have to
find a way to justify the critical race
theory curriculum
under a strict scrutiny test adding
that's a very high bar to me
in the class taught by bass a
self-described white irish-american
citizen
clark was allegedly forced to reveal his
race gender
sexual and religious identities and
attach labels to the identities
which the lawsuit claims violated his
right to privacy
an instructional slide included in court
documents displays dominant groups in
american culture as white male
middle upper class heterosexual and
protestant christian
while everyone else is categorized as
submissive
labels like white are associated with
bass are associated by bass with
privilege while words like female and
working class
are associated with oppressive it's
really
twisted this kind of stuff yeah
yeah that's that's a particularly
egregious but this is happening
all over the place you know um and
gabrielle clark stood up and said no no
thanks i'm not i'm not gonna do this
i was given a similar one of my uh
colleagues was like
uh offered to help uh educate me and i
took her up on it i was like okay um
i'm gonna i'm gonna have an open mind
and she handed me a worksheet and it did
have that
the oppressed it was two columns
oppressed
and um it was dominant group and
subordinated group and the dominant
group only had like one
thing like race was white gender male
religion christian you know and then
over here you had all
like everybody else in the entire world
and i was like wow
that was a very reductionist view
of the world but that sounds it's very
similar to what
uh william experienced and i believe i
think he was the only white presenting
person in
in his class too which made it
especially
have you taken have you taken the
privilege test where it's like a slider
bar and it's like how white are you how
christian are you how old are you oh the
intersectionality score
yeah something like that then it's like
you are 74 points privileged out of 100
you are very privileged or whatever
yeah that's basically what they're doing
uh have you ever seen that that
image of the three people staying at the
fence for the
equality equity of course the amazing
thing about that is is its manipulation
it's the
the insidiousness of it where they show
that to children
and they explain very simply hey we can
give
you know one of the one of the boxes
from the tall guy to the short guy so
they can all see right
well that's simple it makes sense but
what happens when you're dealing with
race
and orientation and national origin and
religion it's impossible to quantify
how standing on top of religion allows
you to see a baseball game
so these are the kinds of manipulative
tactics they use where you kind of
understand it but here's here's what i
truly despise about this
that equality versus equity argument is
about wealth
not race the person who everyone who
gets access to
a a a box to stand on
is their access to resources giving the
shorter person two boxes
is giving them access to resources to
help them
the argument that we actually need to be
having is about class issues
well they do mention working class and
middle upper class as part of the
oppression scale
but when they when they make everything
about your race
that that in my opinion is meant to
disrupt
actual what's what's the right word for
it i guess
social justice real social justice oprah
all of a sudden becomes oppressed
and she's a billionaire and then a white
homeless veteran
is now an oppressor because he's white
yeah it's like saying oprah winfrey has
more in common with
um somebody living in is it east
like the marcy projects in new york yeah
than than a wealthy white person
right clearly that's a false but that's
that's that's the kind of narrative they
use like they they used it with serena
williams
when she had uh so she's the famous
tennis player
when she had a bout of rage you know
with all due respect
she got angry and she like bounced her
tennis racket or something like that
they they penalized her for it and then
there was this big narrative that the
only reason they did it was because she
was a black woman
and that they were basically attacking
her as the trope of the angry black
woman
as opposed to the fact that she just
acted out in violation of the rules
and to act like one of the most famous
celebrated and wealthy athletes in the
world
in any way oppressed is just shockingly
i don't know
ignorant in my opinion but i i think
it's part of the weaponization that we
see from a lot of people i mean
heaven forbid there's a large push
towards
you know stripping away the resources of
corrupt politicians who somehow make
millions of dollars off of their office
when they're getting a salary for 174
000 a year and then also become worth 50
million dollars or 5 million
or whatever they don't want you to come
after them so they'll say hey don't look
at me
it's the uh uh it's the the white guy go
yell at that guy in the gutter who's you
know
shoveling garbage for a living he's the
real oppressor
they teach it yeah it's just like uh
jackie blair is the
the dining person who was falsely
accused is the
the real oppressor yeah the janitor yeah
it makes it this is truly i mean people
say all the time this divide and conquer
like
it makes it impossible for us to
organize long class lines and really
if we were really talking about power if
that's the conversation we want to have
then we need to be talking about class
definitely i see it it's really
interesting donald trump called for 2000
checks for everybody in the stimulus and
it was the republican party that said no
and it shows you that donald trump
really was an insurgent in the
republican party they did not like what
he had what he had to offer
and then after donald trump says 2000
checks joe biden's like 1400.
you know he's like okay so we're we
already gave you the 600 we're only
going to be 1400 right now
but there's something interesting about
trump supporters and left populists
in that i don't think trump supporters
care all that much about billionaires
i i think there's certainly a
conservative argument against
giving the government too much power so
when they talk about wealth taxes right
it's a big thing we see on the left the
bernie sanders
crowd they want a wealth tax you know i
used to i thought about this
are you familiar with the wealth tax um
is that
yang it's bernie sanders and elizabeth
okay yes right the billionaire tax or
something the way it works is
they treat wealth like property and tax
a percentage of your hard wealth you got
to pay for
now i've been very critical of this
because it makes literally no sense
you know jeff bezos for instance i think
his total income from amazon is like 1.3
million dollars per year
his net worth however is like a hundred
and you know 60 billion or whatever or
more at this point because amazon's
you know gaining a lot of value because
the pandemic but he can't sell that
stock
there's like thresholds and contractual
agreements to where he can finally
liquidate some of those assets
that means what if they implement this
wealth tax they're like bezos will pay
you know three billion dollars a year
but he's worth
you know uh hundred and something
billion and it's like
okay well where does that billion
dollars come from the government doesn't
want stock in amazon and you can't give
it up anyway it's a violation of the
contract the wealth tax makes no sense
he doesn't have the cash to actually pay
for it we hear a lot from the left well
then he should sell his assets i'm like
he legally can't
the wealth text makes no sense at this
point however i'm kind of like
i don't care do it let's see what
happens i don't care about jeff bezos
mackenzie bezos
the only thing where i'm kind of like i
don't know elon musk probably deserves
to have a lot of money because that
guy's building starships and starlink
and other useful things
bezos i don't like soros i don't like
the koch brothers the mercers any one of
these billionaires
i don't like i think they flood money
into politics
they they subvert the will of the
working class
and i think many trump supporters would
much prefer working-class individuals
have their say-so as opposed to
billionaires
namely george soros who they criticize
all the time but i think we can throw
out all the names of
tom steyer michael bloomberg left-wing
billionaires right-wing billionaires
i don't care for any one of these
billionaires i think we do need to have
a reckoning on class
issues the problem is critical race
theory disrupts that
the culture war disrupts that and i
think we have a really strong
opportunity right now with biden in
office
to actually look at some of these
anti-woke
leftists many socialists and
progressives and be like
which part can we agree on where we
think the billionaires are disrupting
the will of the working class
and kind of like put a stop to that you
know what i mean i think
and we've mentioned this many times
critical race theory was introduced
by powerful interests who knew it could
distract the masses and create a fight
that protects them
right so there's this comic we love to
reference on the show where it's a rich
guy in his office
everything's really pretty outside is an
occupy wall street protester holding a
big sign saying occupy wall street
and the rich guys on the phone smiling
saying introduce them to identity
politics
and that's really what it feels like
because i was at occupy when this
happened
it went from you know people like luke
kowski who was on the show for a couple
months maybe he'll come back we'll see
luke where are you at luke where yet uh
but he's he's
he's a center-right libertarian i'm
center-left libertarian
but we agree on these libertarian issues
not liking the elites the authoritarians
and we met at occupy wall street because
these people were down there
until the critical race theorists show
up and started segregating people based
on race
and then you saw people leave and get
angry that was the ultimate slap in the
face and the insult
especially to a lot of younger white
idealistic individuals who are now being
told it was their fault
and they're like yo i'm here at occupy
wall street with you it's like too bad
that happened to me literally i went
occupy wall street with the constitution
i was going to read it
and they were like hey the news is here
i was like oh good i'll go get on the
news and tell them about the
constitution and how we need to break
the federal reserve up
no there's too many white people have
spoken to the news i just lost my mind i
got on stage
and screamed that i'm not white and no
one is black or white
these shades don't exist in our
pigmentation or skin color and people
looked at me like dumbfounded
that's another girl that went up was
like i am a black woman who and i was
just like i give up on this i give up i
can't
i can't fight the crowd i have to find
another way
but man it is being silence not the
answer
it was a it was a brilliant attack
vector in my opinion
accusing people who oppose racism of
being the true racists
yeah you know the other problem is the
left right thing um
just the massive fear of of
people on the and i i know these the
terms are probably
are meaningless that's kind of the point
but
people are classical liberals right who
are on the left who are like the ground
has now shifted hold on
classical liberal is a right-wing
position yeah so
right so so people confuse the tradition
like the actual classical liberalism of
like john locke
with saying 90s democrat liberal you
know what i mean
so right in the left is another attack
vector thing right it doesn't really
exist
well yeah it does it it does these words
the colloquialisms of left and right are
confused and meaningless
so there's social liberalism which is
like democrats in the 90s
slightly that's what i mean social
liberalism social liberalism
right so okay this is this is the
liberalism of like martin luther king jr
expanded civil rights civil rights
protections and social programs
but social liberalism is not social
social democracy or democratic socialism
or socialism
social liberalism is like center left
meaning
some programs sometimes
and then classical liberalism is like
not that many programs but
yeah that's right classical liberalism
is like smaller government
yeah it's very much like libertarianism
yeah and then social liberalism
is you think we should have the 1964
civil rights act
you think unemployment benefits and a
social safety net is a good thing
my i do i believe all of those things i
just think conservatives have fair
criticisms of these programs in that
they become bloated
congested and corrupt over over too long
and so we need to
reassess i think a liberal and
conservative is another attack vector
thing dividing us because i'm both yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it it really and i see there's so
many people i mean
like i know you you all know this well
but
i was still a little surprised when i
went on tucker carlson i made my video
and i said in my video i'm a lifelong
liberal
and i went on tucker and tucker's like
lifelong liberal jody shaw
how many emails i got afterwards saying
you know i was with you
but then you went on tucker and and he's
right wing so
i can't i'm not for i'm not with you
anymore even though my message
had not changed at all and so that's
when i
i realized this is a big problem is that
people who otherwise
um would be able to see this stuff in
their midst the crc stuff and be like
well this is wrong but they're still
kind of confused
if they're they're so scared of if they
go off par the script
of being associated with the right and
that fear is so
big i mean there's like it's like an
epithet to be called right wing
to to some lib to some liberals identity
politics to say i
am a fill in the blank is identity
politics to say i am
center is identity politics i am left
identity i am a democrat identity
this identity crap yes we need to
we need to drop it there's a quote from
andrew
breitbart that uh i think you should
hear i wonder what your opinion is on
andrew breitbart
i don't know yes he's a he breitbart
magazine right uh website he he passed
some years ago
but he said walk toward the fire don't
worry about what they call you
all those things are set against you
because they want to stop you in your
tracks
but if you keep going you're sending a
message to people who are rooting for
you who are agreeing with you
the message is that they can do it too
love it there was another quote which
was either derivative of this or
spawned from it where that you know i've
often misattributed to breitbart but
it's similar
walk towards the fire people think that
once you get to the fire you'll be
burned but in reality you'll pass
through
and see freedom on the other side yeah
i've heard that quote before that's
true i think that i've experienced that
so these people
are scared and there's a lot of there's
a lot of like uh
you know moderate leftist personalities
and
i shouldn't say leftists like
traditional and classical liberal types
that are absolutely terrified of finding
themselves
in in league with conservatives but if
you live that way
then you're living on your knees so i
don't care
i i i had a uh there's probably some hit
piece coming out against uh about me
soon probably and i get this thing where
they're like tim poole has hosted
alex jones and enrique tario and these
people
they like to do this thing where they're
like here's a photo of tim poole sitting
down
at a bar with the alt-right and i'm like
uh-huh
and i don't care i really don't i've
you know they they come at me and
they're like can you explain this photo
tim yeah i talk to people that that's
about it
i'll talk to whatever i feel like
talking about i don't care about what
they call me
i don't care about what they think i
literally do not care
i just don't and and if you do you are
being held back because
they have no control over you they don't
now look i get it
i think there's a lot of people who are
like i don't want to lose my job i'm
comfortable
but if you think keeping your head down
will keep you safe you are wrong
they will come for you eventually i mean
you kind of explained that in your story
before where you thought if you just
went along with things that kind of
kept your head down is that yeah yeah
that's that's how you felt
yeah they will come for you i mean these
i i you can't it's it's getting to a
point where you are it's compelled i
mean
look at the clark v democracy that's
about compelled speech
this is now we are now not talking about
like suppression of speech we're talking
about they're
you're going to be asked to say things
that you do not necessarily believe in
as a continued condition of your
employment or you're getting a good
grade
you're going to lose your job unless you
bend the knee so if you would rather
live
on your knees than then then fight on
your feet well then so be it that's what
you deserve and it's what you want and
far be it for me to criticize you
no you should criticize because that
lends to the problem it
exacerbates the problem don't do it
listen i'm not here to recreate the
environment they've created
they want to create this environment
where they terrify you into dropping to
your knees
i don't want to create an environment
where you're terrified of my side
i'm going to tell you this you do your
thing if you do right i've got your back
but if you want to live on your knees
i'm not going to criticize you or
pressure you i mean no i will i'll
criticize you i'll criticize you
but i'm not going to create the same
environment where you are not welcome
if you want to live in this world where
you are at the behest of the woke cult
with no real ideology just
strange do as the tribe says or else
that's up to you
you're welcome to come on the show you
want to taste it yeah if you want to
taste it and then come tell your
personal story about how bad it sucked
go for it but don't do it
get up off your feet i think it's very
simple off your knees i i grew up
i grew up in chicago off your toes off
your job
i grew up super far left i was a
skateboarder i was an anarchist
i was listening to all the punk rock
music and then like i thought the system
i hated the system i had been i had been
messed with by cops before so i was all
just like cops are corrupt the system is
broken
this is you know it's terrible the war
machine and then i got older and
realized
there's nuance in ways to deal about
deal with these problems but having
grown up
kind of in not necessarily the gutter
but in a sense
you know guttery conditions i've also
been homeless a couple times there's
nothing anyone can take from me
i don't care you have nothing over me oh
you can take my job away
so what what's the worst case scenario
been there done that i'm not worried
about it
and so i'm free to speak my mind
i'm not scared but there are a lot of
people who are scared because they're
going to lose everything
well also because there's that fire you
know this fear it's not just about
losing your job it's about
literally being cast out of your herd
and i think that's partially
himself i think partially that's why
this ideology is so effective it hooks
into this
that's a primal fear like getting you're
gonna get eaten by a lion
exaggeration humans are social shaming
yes
we are social creatures we survive with
cooperation
so when you're out on your own you are
in a very risky position
but together we're strong the threat is
you will be excised well let me tell
everybody who's listening
there's very clearly an infrastructure
built where you will survive
opposing the cult of wokeness we're all
here we're having a good time in fact i
got to tell you
i'm doing all right for myself i love
when they try claiming grifter right
i'm sure they call you a grifter because
you raised all this money yes what's
easier losing your job freaking out your
friends becoming a social pariah in your
in your industry in your community
or going along pushing the narrative and
just milking it for all it's worth
what's safer being a woke neoliberal
leftist promoting joe biden and the
democrat message
to make money on the platforms that will
you have no risk of being banned for
or challenging the system and facing
real risk of getting your your shows
deleted every single day
or getting fired from your job and
crossing your fingers
that there will be people who agree with
you to donate to your gofundme they call
you a grifter
yet at the same time they do literally
the same thing plus they have
institutional support
not only do these woke leftists who try
and pull some bs at schools
they've they've raised eighty thousand
dollars in several instances they've
rated t
raised tens of thousands of dollars they
then get propped up by magazines by
newspapers
these same people can appear on jimmy
kimmel and these late night shows
they're not gonna do that for you tucker
carlson will and then people will get
freaked out so which is
easier you want to talk about the real
grift it's the youtubers
who are on the left it's the youtubers
who tow the the party is the party line
and the establishment line knowing
they will never get banned for this and
have nothing to worry about and can milk
it for all it's worth even when they put
out fake news
the real risk they call it the grift
they're only saying that because they
want to stop you dead in your tracks
like breitbart said
now speaking out against the
establishment is as risky as you can get
because we know people get banned they
get shut down i mean gofundme froze
your account for for an administrative
reason mind you
but gofundme has deleted the the the
fundraisers for
many conservatives it's not it's not
it's
not a grift yeah it's interesting though
how it gets framed
you're talking about these other
youtubers these social justice warriors
they frame it as if they're counter
culture
they're they're fighting against the
power
you know and it's like they don't i
don't know if
it's hard for me to believe that they
don't understand that they are part of
the power that this is the establishment
they are
literally the power it's like since when
what
since when was the group aligned with
the the major political parties
well the democrats at least and like
coca-cola
the resistance yeah that's right you
know coca-cola nike
and you know the company the aclu i mean
every
just about every major institution in
this country and every major news outlet
just about
mainstream media i really really love
wokeness in these companies that use
slave labor
because it's just like they're like
we're here because we think racism is
wrong
meanwhile they're literally operating
sweatshops that pay like a quarter an
hour or whatever just like
yeah awful conditions hiring
paramilitary groups to go in and
suppress
workers rights groups in foreign
countries although those amazing
obviously
that's not a principled stance that's
just
business tactics but i mean i often
wonder about
you know the true believers um i
remember at smith i could
kind of get in i mean i talked to a lot
of people in hallways but i could kind
of if you
you know you can kind of tell who the
true believers are you kind of just get
a vibe
you know when you when you're talking
about the stuff and the eye contact
some i think it's a very small
percentage i don't think they're such
thing as true believers well
guys no no i think there's just like
mindless tribal zealots
and what they what they really believe
is it look there's nothing to believe
in critical race theory the theory
itself makes no sense i'll give you an
example
six months ago asians were white they
were they were
they were called white adjacent they
were called literally white
the argument was that white is a social
structure and not a race therefore
asians were white
we were joking on this show in response
to the narrative i was double white
well then something changed and now you
know these these hate crimes started
happening
because of the you know the covet stuff
and for a variety of reasons
now there's the stop asian hate movement
which good mind you i respect that i
think hate crimes are wrong
but now all of a sudden asians are
minorities again so what happened is you
have
some individuals there's one woman who
at her at her school she's a member of a
school board i think in like sacramento
was disparaging asians calling them
racial slurs
well because it was allowed in 2016
asians were white
universities were discriminated against
them legally because they were over
privileged
now that that's changed they're calling
for her resignation but she's a black
woman
so there are people like james lindsay
who point out when
a black you know woman is getting
cancelled for
racism towards asian the structure is
inverting it's like collapsing on itself
i don't necessarily think it's
collapsing i think it's just proof that
there are literally no ideals or
principles
and they can change on a dime to fit the
needs of the cult
so they'll say six months ago well no
asians aren't actually minorities
they're privileged white people they
make tons of money and they're going to
go to
universities hate crimes happen now it's
beneficial to them again
they changed the narrative and
sacrificed their own zealots
who believed their own narratives so
there's there's no core ideology there's
no true believers
just tribal zealots who will do whatever
the tribe says which is why
it's very difficult to interview these
people outside of their safe spaces
do you think that's why i've been
wondering about the popularity of zombie
movies for a long time
right right to the analogy i think
[Music]
i think i've been wondering like why are
zombie movies so popular i started
thinking this a few years ago and now
i'm like
maybe maybe it has something to do with
this they have a
deep down they have a desire to just be
the zombie they want like so
we all watch zombie movies terrified and
they watch it longingly
like oh to be a zombie and just not have
a brain anymore
not have to think the cdc's been putting
out zombie stuff about zombies and like
i think it's a dehumanization effort
maybe consciously maybe subconsciously i
don't know but like i think that's a
joke
people start starving and and are on the
street eating other human bodies because
they're starving to death
and then it's like it's okay to kill
them because they're zombies i think
cdc is trying to be silly and put out a
joke yeah like in the holdem here in uh
the ussr in like i don't know what 30
years or 40s or something 50s maybe
that people were starving to death and
eating yes and it was
you know that happens um so i think that
it is a desensitization movement
maybe not maybe it's intentional i never
thought it was before i think you're
reading way too much into it yeah
it's so weird that i went so deep on
that i don't know i think there's
something there is something incredibly
dehumanizing about crt
definitely um it's it creates makes us
into it
reduces us to racial objects or
commodities even
it it treats you like a member of a hive
collective that has no individuality
and and that it's really interesting
it's almost like invasion of the body
snatchers
these these people almost just i mean
they obviously care about themselves
they want power for themselves
but they get sacrificed like i mentioned
that that woman on the school board
now being told to resign because of
anti-asian you know racism
they don't care the hive will will will
cut off whatever it needs to to gain
power
so when you join this you are quite
literally a mindless cog a mindless
gnat swarming in the hive whose strength
is derived from each
individual cog but they'll they'll swat
you and
destroy you i was thinking about so well
the interesting thing is i wonder
i wonder about this you know i think
there is a
there are a lot of lines as to what
divides the culture war
authoritarian versus libertarian
nationalist versus globalist
collectivist versus individualist
and ideologue versus like pragmatist or
things like this
and there's there's no clear dividing
line they all play a role in this
but i will say there are many people who
are
when you say true believers i don't
think they actually believe in anything
other than they're a part of the cult so
that
that's what i want to clarify they
obviously believe in the cult
but there's no real ideology or
principles to believe in
the structure is amorphous and makes
little sense but
they are propped up by cowards by people
who say
i'm going to keep my head down and i'll
be fine they won't be
they'll sacrifice their own obama called
it a circular firing squad
so they're they're they're only propped
up by
two groups of people in my opinion for
one they have their ranks for sure but
the two people are those
who are mindless ignorant to what's
going on they have no idea
and so they're just like i don't know
whatever you see these people on twitter
saying cancel culture is not real
and there's like twi regular people i
see like on instagram
there was a there's a skateboarding
account
uh one of the most prominent in the
world called the barracks and they
tweeted what are your thoughts on cancel
culture
and i saw some like 17 year old kid
who's like a skateboarder saying cancel
culture's not real
the kid has no idea what he's talking
about his photos were like fishing and
skateboarding
clearly he's not experienced or watched
anything that's going on
so he genuinely doesn't believe it and
so he jumps in and defends them
ignorantly but then you have people who
know exactly what's happening
and are like well i'd rather be on this
side because i think they're going to
win
in the end they won't but they're hoping
that when the dust settles and the
conflict ends
i'll tell you this these people have one
thing right
we we the people who believe in
individual liberties and freedoms
and civil rights we're the good guys
historically
the ones who fought for civil rights
freedom liberty etc have always been the
good guys at least
in recent history and they know if we
win
they'll be fine what are we gonna do you
know some some woke person comes out and
goes
i was wrong about being woke i'm so
sorry yep guess what
all the anti-white people are going to
be like thank you but what happens to
the anti-woke should the woke win
what do you think yeah you you i saw
that that that premise
yeah it's not just what's going to
happen to the antiwar it's going to
happen to the woke too
absolutely cultural revolutions i mean
all the intelligentsia
i'll call this the uh it's something
i've brought up before
but i'll call it the intersectionalist
wager
if you are anti-woke and the anti-woke
win
you're fine if you are woke and the
anti-woke win
you are fine but if you are woke
and the and the uh if you are if you are
woke and the woke win
you're at risk but you're going to keep
your head down hopefully you'll be safe
but if you're anti-woke and the woke win
they'll they'll come for you and they'll
destroy your life
so ultimately you look at this equation
and you have many people saying
the safer bet is to pretend to be woke
because in the event that the anti-woke
side wins
they're not going to do anything bad to
me but if you challenge wellness the
woke will
absolutely destroy you i think it's a
bad bet i agree
i i think more importantly whether it's
a bad bet or not
i think there's reasons to believe it is
i just think
it's morally unsound and i would rather
die on my feet than live on my knees
and how about another great great quote
from uh zapita or is that what was the
name zapito was his name
emily emilio zappatista that's a weird
last name yeah he said
uh i would rather be a slave to
principles than a slave to men
and that guy's a leftist that was that
guy was a socialist revolutionary
but those quotes are are are meaningful
so i wonder
will you just bend the knee and be a
servant to
this cult you know i was thinking about
identity because i was talking
poorly about it earlier about like i'm
on the left i'm uh
i'm a democrat whatever and it's it's
insanity to to like
stake who you are based off of some
label but
in the same rate i'm a crossland that's
my last name i'm a human
i'm a human that's a that's an identity
i'm playing identity games when i say
i'm a human identity is a real thing
dude yeah and it keeps us sane
so these people are like finding sanity
in
identifying with a group now i think
it's too
i think it's too meticulous to say i the
color of the skin has starts to have to
do with it because i think it's more of
a class issue personally like gandhi he
revolted against the white
british imperialist but he was revolting
against the conquest
and the capitalizing of his country it
wasn't didn't matter what color the
skins were
now hopefully i think we can take that
moving forward i wish i had something
more uh profound to say after that
you go vacation listen when you go back
far enough and
nations and cultures were divine were
divided by race
like countries were literally a group of
people who were one race
it's easy to see how racism emerged
because they were like
i know who's in my country and who will
protect me and that person looks
different
but we're now in an era of you can fly
across the planet in a matter of hours
we live in a country that's the great
american melting pot martin luther king
jr's dream
was correct his point was correct the
civil rights movement was correct
in order for us to now function in this
in this
amazing new reality we have to treat
people
we have to we have to treat them uh
based on the content of their character
the color of their skin
or their political affiliation well i
disagree
i think why uh nazis yeah but not all
nazis were evil
oh come on no just because they
identified with that party didn't make
them evil some of them
like hated the violence if you are a cog
in that machine
that is you know advocating for genocide
i'm sorry
i'm gonna discriminate against you it's
like you gotta say the chinese communist
party a lot of those people
aren't aren't evil or yes they're just
stuck in that system no no no no no you
join the chinese communist party
regular citizens don't have to join and
become party members well the chinese
communist party is something they choose
to be a part of
listen i think most politics i can
respect within certain boundaries
but there are political factions i don't
care for and i'm not going to do it yeah
true good point good point i'm talking
about the conservative liberals
that ian was referring to earlier that
uh liberals and maybe conservancy need
to get over
i don't think we have any hope of
toppling this
woke invasion unless we can link arms
with each other yeah i'll double down i
i think that maybe the the ideology of
the nazi party is dangerous but the
individuals aren't necessarily
no this is because they affiliate with
somebody the problem is conservatives
are not nazis
and the woke left and the establishme
establishment machine claimed they were
and then they used a very natural
predisposition for regular people who
hate racism bigotry and genocide
you go to a regular person and say would
you link at arms with a nazi and they're
going to say
no way right because they're completely
agree they're afraid of the word
nazi now i'm not talking about i'm
talking about a literal uniform wearing
nazi
they don't exist dude okay ian
my point is there are neo-nazis with
tattoos and swastikas on their chests
i will never join with them in any
capacity politically
you didn't you said it you were you were
up in berkeley and you met an auntie
and i i interviewed a guy about certain
things some guy that was antifa but he
actually was cool
so is that antifa guy advocating for
wiping out of people based on their race
not that guy
but i mean a lot of those people are
dangerous but not everyone that
identifies with antifa is dangerous
i don't think you understand there's no
point going in circle so moving on yeah
we'll have to do a show on this the
point i'm making is that there are
political factions i will never
i think you're taking it too far that's
too extreme okay you go you go link arms
to the nazis congratulations
bro people can be look at what's his
name uh never gonna daryl davis people
can be retrofitted there there are
communists you got people out of the
clan there are there are hard communists
and there are neo-nazis that i'm not
going
to join
ian you're not understanding the
conversation okay jody is talking about
linking arms
with certain groups to resist wokeness
there are the nazis where were white
identitarians
why would i join identitarians to fight
identities it's never going to happen
yeah it's
it's kind of this similar thing right or
let's call it authoritarianism
well there's a difference though right
so well i'm sure there is
that i don't know but look there could
be libertarian identitarians
and i'm not a fan of their ideology and
i think it's wrong granted i'll give
them more respect in not
beating and caging and killing people
for sure the thor tan's the ones who do
that
but identitarianism in my opinion is a
problem and
they're i'm not gonna i agree i i agree
it's a problem
um i guess
to me basically when i think this this
wokeness is a form of authoritarianism
clearly and um that
things like and you could argue the same
for the
nazis neo-nazis right that's that's
authoritarianism as well like that
that's
the all anything that's identitarianism
right is like
well you you can be you can be awoke uh
you can be woke and be
libertarian in that you would calmly and
peacefully advocate for your beliefs
and say these things without forcing
people yes without insulting them
without coercing them exceeding them
when you see antifa
who are identitarian because antifa is a
nebulous term
when you see leftist identitarian groups
going around beating people and many
antifa are
you know but the flag is a nebulous
reference to like communism
then you know the these you can have
someone
actually let me let me say this because
i've said it before i met a communist
guy
in berkeley and he told me antifa was
wrong for beating and attacking people
and that true communism would never
support that and i was like all right
well there you go we can we can break
bread and have a conversation i think is
that the other guy
referencing yeah we we i think your
ideology is bad
but if you're not authoritarian then
we're all right
the problem is communism itself is
arguably authoritarian because
libertarian the libertarian spectrum of
the left doesn't scale up into large
numbers
anybody who truly wants a communist
society will never implement it
without force it doesn't work it doesn't
scale
so libertarian versus authoritarian i
think
is a different argument but a deserving
one you know authoritarianism is bad
that's the problem
it centralizes power it corrupts systems
and it causes them to break down which
is why
all of these communist countries fail
however
the chinese communist party learned from
the failures of these other countries
implemented capitalist
policies and institutions to protect
their party control and authoritarian
authoritarianism in their country
and they're a weird kind of
pseudo-communism i guess
it's an authoritarian regime it doesn't
matter what you call it fascist
communist whatever
it's one party rule and they oppress
their people to get what they want
yeah and that's why i think the
left-right distinction is meaningless
when authoritarianism comes to town left
right's kind of a luxury
of a functioning democracy or however
imperfect
i think it's divide and conquer yeah the
communists use it a mall used to
they talk about rightists a bunch when
you when you see
mao when you see conservatives
and you know right now there's a big gun
control thing going on on twitter
there was uh kyle kalinski tweeted a
poll
about gun control he was like gun
control should we have strict regulation
light regulation no regulation ban guns
most of his followers said strict
regulation
but a ton of his followers who are
leftists said quote
under no pretext that is the left the
leftist version of
shall not be infringed so many people on
the right
will reference the second amendment the
right to keep and bear arms shall not be
infringed and they'll quote that and
they'll respond to people when talking
about gun control
for the leftists it's karl marx who said
under no pretext should ammunition and
arms be surrendered
the working class should frustrate any
attempt even by force if necessary
so the leftist reference marks saying
don't give up your guns and the right
references the constitution saying we
can keep our guns
and it's interesting then when these two
factions could probably agree
and have something meaningful linking
arms and going against the establishment
the corporatists the authoritarians so i
look at
you know i got i got into a mini
argument with cameron caskey who is one
of the parkland
kids and he's very pro gun control but i
think the general assessment is
he's not really pro gun control he's
just trolling on twitter
so i'm like okay maybe i walked into
that and he was trolling me but
his position is authoritarian right the
seizure of weapons because even the
authoritarian left
commies are like pro-gun there's only
one faction that's like authoritarian
centrist and right-leaning
that want to take people's guns away so
to see like these establishment
personalities basically advocating for
authoritarian right-wing positions
well there you go you know what the
problem is i suppose the the the left
and the right
actual you know populists and even the
anti-foot types who are authoritarian
all agree we should have our guns karl
marx said it even got authoritarian left
saying people can keep their guns
so how can we make that happen then
i think people can be de-radicalized i
love this daryl davis are you familiar
with his story
no is that that was was that the movie i
don't think they made it
daryl davis is a jazz musician he's a
black man and he went to clan rallies
and then talked to them and through
conversation
and being friends de-radicalized them
yeah i knew daryl davis
but he quite literally opposed them
every step of the way and was extremely
critical of their beliefs yeah you gotta
i mean you gotta
so there's a difference between linking
arms with somebody and going to their
face and saying you're wrong here's why
yeah not not approaching the crowd but
the individuals is a really really great
story you're gonna love it
daryl davis a black man sitting in a
truck with a white clan member
and the klan member made a disparaging
comment about the genetics of
of black people daryl davis told him he
was wrong
he was like that's not true he's like
i'm not i'm not the way you describe you
know black people
and he said the clan member told him oh
it's because your genes are recessive
so then daryl looks at the clan member
and says did you know that there's a
gene in white people to make them
predisposed to be serial killers
and the clan member was like what that's
not true and daryl said
name a black serial killer and then the
clan guy was like wait a minute
and then he was like but i'm not a
serial killer and then daryl responded
oh it's recessive in you
and it was a really great smackdown of
this guy who didn't quite understand
what he was talking about
and then that guy that's that's one of
daryl davis stories
through conversations telling these guys
you were wrong one of the one of the
most amazing stories he had
was that he met this clan member who was
a big rock and roll fan
and there was this famous car i guess i
don't know a lot about the cars and
daryl being a you know
well-known musician was like oh yeah i
can get you to go and check out that car
i can get you into that you know museum
whatever to see it and like sitting or
whatever
and this clan guy all of a sudden was
like no way daryl brings him to this i
guess it was a museum or whatever
and you get to see this legendary
vehicle from a rock and roll legend and
this clan guy just had this profound
moment where he was like i can't believe
it
you know everything they were telling us
was not true daryl davis just did this
like made his life like it was a dream
come true and it was a it was
you know a black guy who did it the
racist narratives are lies
and so i challen i question anybody
who's trying to divide us
and make us fight each other and i
really do think a large component
is powerful special interests elites
billionaires the billionaires and the
millionaires
who have an interest in making us fight
each other instead of them
when they're dumping hundreds of
millions of dollars like tom steyer into
our elections
to subvert our rights and he did steyer
was flooding
flooding the zone with all this money to
strip away our right to bear arms
and leftists and conservatives agree we
have a right to do that
that's the problem bernie's right about
that i wish he was more vocal on the
millionaire's part i guess he's bringing
it back so
but that story you told i mean daryl
davis that was
an individual those were individual
conversations it's not like he was up in
front of a group trying to convince the
whole group that part of it is
getting people out of the the
you called it a cult getting them alone
i guess and developing
a relationship humanizing humanizing
the other side if it's a non-theistic
religion
so when i i was talking to james lindsey
peter bergoge and helen pluck was a few
years ago when they did the so-called
squared thing
and the way peter begosion described it
was it's a religion
and when people said there's no deity
and he says buddhism doesn't have a
deity either
so it's a non-theistic religion they
follow it's very similar
they have you know they shun the
disbelievers there's
some form of confession i guess that
doesn't seem to work original sin
yeah there's original sin privilege i
got a feeling it's like a damn
built up with like this energy flow
that's blockaded by this like racist
ideology and if you chip away at it
piece by piece like person by person and
have the conversations
eventually it cracks and bursts open and
there will be a flood of like
this energy that we're trying to free
this yeah it's like a house of cards
like it
just pull out a few
is that what you're talking about yeah
you know the problem is we're the good
guys
we're playing by the rules we're trying
to be honest we're trying to recognize
our own faults
and our goodwill is being exploited by
con artists deceivers manipulators and
zealots
they can cheat because they don't care
to them the ends justify the means
to us we're trying to create a better
world so they can exploit that good will
they can exploit free speech for
instance
i for instance have defended the free
speech of the left and the right
and i love it when they post where all
the conservatives defending the free
speech of you know the bds movement and
i'm like
i'm right here i'm i'm you know or i'm
i'm the free speech individual
not the conservative or anything but
they don't they don't return
the same favor when uh a good example
when uh
a journal to the new york times was
being heavily criticized by all these
outlets
the media calls it a a harassment
campaign
when the same media then targets our
harassment campaign against conservative
individuals they all laugh and gloat so
i can sit here and be like
stop name-dropping people to drive you
know
a flood of emails their way it's a waste
of time criticize the institutions
it's meaningless to them they don't care
they're not going to praise me they're
going to respect me for doing that
but i do it because it's the right thing
to do they won't return that which means
we're at a very serious disadvantage
yeah it's an information war
really i like internet video because you
can reach individuals
in mass yeah the internet yeah the video
i made was
was did very well in terms of views like
a lot of people saw it and resonated
with it and i'm very
happy um that i i hear from people now
who are saying
you know that was that helped me um
and i i don't think everyone can just
wake up and make a video but i
i always tell people uh you can
part of what helen pluck rose is doing
right with counterweight
counterweight support this is an
organization in the uk that helps people
affected by woke ideology in their
workplace or their school
is that she has a community there where
people can talk to other people and
essentially deprogram because when
you're in an environment when where
you're sitting at a table and somebody
says you know rich white women rich
white women and nobody
says anything you kind of you just kind
of think maybe i'm crazy
maybe like you start to doubt uh
what's what's reality what's real and
you start to think am i racist like
because i think that's unprofessional or
so i think it's really important to find
at least one other person you can talk
to to get a reality check
and and that's counterweight does that
really well and i
i think we need more ways to find each
other so when people do speak out they
become like lightning rods you know like
emails pour in jonathan k the quillette
journalist was talking about this about
how whenever he publishes an article
about higher education
all these faculty and students write to
him and say hey here's my story and i
can't and i'm afraid
and so it's like they need a way to find
each other like instead of just
going to the the one person who spoke
out we don't have
any infrastructure to support i mean our
entire infrastructure has been captured
we don't have any infrastructure to
support these people
and and that's part that's a major
problem we're starting we're starting to
get built
it's starting to get built yeah
decentralized too so that central
servers can't shut you down
because that stuff if it threatens the
narrative they'll try and pull the plot
yeah i heard about that there's somebody
working on there's a lot of software
working on rss3 there's pocket net
is doing stuff yeah they sponsor the
show periodically very cool
decentralized apps minds has something
called um
nomad that's kind of a project that
mines is working on
there's a lot i mean the decentralized
movement is huge right now
um you've got to be very helpful yeah
isps are still centralized which is a
problem so we'll have to eventually
build a decentralized isp
internet service provider i think the
infrastructure gets built when we get
people to
just stand up for themselves and start
building it and so long as there are
people who are cowering in fear
understanding what's happening but not
wanting to stick their necks out
then you know there you go another good
one it's odyssey that it's like a
decentralized data flow service they
specialize in video right now it's it's
almost like it's like the matrix
in a lot of ways yeah how can we get
more people to stand out i know aaron
kins
kinswater kinds of arter kinsvader i'm
friends with him i i don't know how
pronounced sorry aaron
yeah a professor faculty at university
of vermont he he made a video
recently talking about he calling it a
secular religion
yeah and um i'm just now they're
demanding his resignation
yeah there was a well there was a
change.org
petition going around but then somebody
uh carlin boyzenko started another one
calling for him to be uh to have the job
of the diversity inclusion equity
czar or whatever the diversity
uh inclusivity and equity uh position is
itself like
a chaplain it's like these institutions
are appointing religious
affirmation officials to these
organizations
i'm guessing they they're probably very
well paid oh yeah yeah yeah
the the religion is infecting these
institutions
and they're creating jobs for them and
people don't resist they're just
allowing the religion to sweep over the
best way i can find to
help to bring light to these people is
to play the long game
like the chinese communist party or
other intelligent long-term but like you
got to make videos
every day i would do two three videos a
day you start to build this following
people that are really listening to you
and then you have the opportunity to
bring other people in like what tim's
doing with this show
and you can start talking on on air like
on the video yeah with other and you
find people like you that are
experiencing it firsthand and you shine
the light on it
and then it just grows so fast like
people like boots on the ground
like other like giving them a platform
and making them feel supported not just
that but one of the things
we're working on outside of this show is
we're planning the vlog
which is going to be a vlog of the house
and crazy shenanigans and we got
chickens and they're small
skateboarding skateboarding and uh now
rollerblading as well for the aggressive
inline people who have been asking us
about wanting to come absolutely you're
all invited and bmx2 bmx2
i want to make this a fun place for
everybody to come and um
you know periodically enjoy various
things music comedy
whatever it is for building culture
we're gonna we're gonna do that kind of
stuff so that people can have an
opportunity to build culture and show
people
the other side of that fire we're having
a good time you guys go get locked down
in your cubicle apartments in new york
city and drop to your knees and pray to
your
your woke uh um you know diversity
inclusivity
and diversity inclusivity and equity
officer
and we're going to be rocking out some
you know old-school rock and roll
and writing new music and i want to make
it red
chickens are going to be everywhere you
know clucking and jumping and there's
cats doing cat stuff
and uh we're gonna be doing tray flips
and tail whips
and macchio grinds or whatever and just
having a good time so
i must say i i have met i i forgot what
it was like to be able to talk with
people openly
and that's right like i i've made so
many friends
since since i came out i i just
i lost a lot of friends you can watch
george carlin again
yeah i can do whatever i want how's your
state of mind shifted
you mentioned earlier that is a good
question um i
when i made that first video it was just
such a relief and i
i think about um my uncle sorry i just
went away from the bike
my uncle um it's a sad story he
he's he's gay he's dead now but he was
gay
and um he had a family he was married
and had children and he didn't
actually come out until he was like in
his 60s
and he would he was so hot much
happier to me um and
it kind of feels maybe like that like it
just felt like
i cannot you are gonna get i cannot over
emphasize that yeah probably they're
gonna be like how dare you compare
being auntie woke to but i hear you
maybe i can say it because
that's stressful i think you're i agree
with you yeah i mean
the secret the telling yourself that the
internal policing causes great psychic
damage and
and i not doing that anymore and
um i i somebody said something about
totalitarianism that it's not a top-down
movement that it's a bottoms up that
people start internally policing
themselves
first and then somebody just steps in
that's how it happens and that's what i
i was doing i was internally pleasing
myself and it's
very damaging i mean a lot of people in
the cultural revolution we had a lot of
suicides and in
in soviet russia too like a lot of
people committed suicide they went crazy
this this stuff even in their own family
they're like
people have to stand up now before it's
too late and hopefully
speaking up is you know the first thing
hopefully we're not too late
there there's some there's some new
stories that make me optimistic
sometimes i'm pessimistic but
when you look at them eating themselves
they're looking for things to cancel
start canceling each other
you know i think i'm fairly optimistic
but how about we jump over these super
chats
what do you guys say oh yeah if you
haven't already smash the like button
because it really does help subscribe to
the channel hit the notification bell
and share the show if you really like it
leave us a good review on itunes and
spotify if you have not done that
already it really does help
and uh did i say smash the like button
definitely all right we got this from
matthew hammond he says
why is it taking so long to hire people
for the tim cast site carla the lotus
eaters is hiring people in a complete
lockdown in the uk
it's not taking a long time we've hired
i think three people in the past like
month and a half
just because you haven't yeah you just
can't see them i guess behind the scenes
yeah there's like a dozen employees now
this company we're growing like crazy
wow uh we got a lot coming a lot more
people
we are uh we are narrowing down our
search for a paranormal podcast producer
so a new show
we have paranormal oh definitely yeah i
mean we talk about dmt and god and all
that stuff way too much
but we're going to be talking about
ghost stories and theories and
i really want to get academics and i
want to have like um
researchers in the paranormal legitimate
academic university researchers
who are not the kooky tv show types so
we're doing all that stuff and it's
actually it's actually happening
the new site might be up even by uh the
end of this week
and then with the new site we're going
to bring out writers and they're going
to start being articles
on you know uh moderate liberal
cultural commentary from other people so
it's going to be
like there's so many conservative sites
like the daily wire the daily caller the
blaze
where's like the anti-woke
anti-establishment liberal version for
like regular moderate individuals
well hopefully i think we'll actually
put that together and you know we'll see
how it rolls
christina h says tim has inspired me to
get chickens we did in fact get chickens
i love the chickens i hung out today for
the first time
so we have the chicken city but right
now they're confined to one building in
the chicken city because they're still
very small
and we're just getting them used to it
so i'm gonna go check them afterwards
make sure they're okay
we've got some motion sensor lights to
scare away predators we've got the fence
double layered might not be enough we're
still gonna be nervous yeah we're still
worried about it
yeah yeah yeah kind of raccoon before
feeding them bugs earlier yes
it's hardcore they're like they're great
they're omnivorous
they will rip bugs apart stink bugs are
chasing each other
stink bugs are all over the place
they're invasive they're massive and
they're everywhere and they're really
dumb and slow but apparently the
chickens just
they they see it and they they can see
the bug before i can it's amazing and
they just
zoom at it and they all fight over it
yeah great i wonder if we
made like tracks if they would go on a
chicken race with the one in the lead
with the bug in his mouth
amazing like running circles around
they're so fun
i already have a favorite they're so
cute here we go zachary bird says ban
dodge ram 2500's
vehicle of choice for duis 4.9 for
4.95 percent source in certify.com
mom's demand high capacity dui vehicles
control now
all white men own large trucks i
actually have a ram 2500.
oh it's nice we got it because we're
going to be going on tour
and the plan is at some point to take an
rv so we do this show
on the road in a variety of cities we
stay in one city for a week
then friday night we do a live show at a
venue we do the podcast
in an actual venue with the audience and
they can
you know yell things or whatever and
then we can yell back and say oh that
sounds awesome
yeah so we're thinking right now the
plan is for the first trip's gonna be
nashville for one week
then we travel over the weekend to
austin then back to nashville
and then back home because we're on the
east coast and um
then from from then on we'll try like
florida and we'll we'll slowly branch
out
and we stay we stay a week in that city
so we can get
a variety of guests from the area so
nashville works out really well there's
tons of you know daily wires there i
guess
but then there's a lot of people in
nashville so that'll be really fun
all right let's see erica baum says high
five tim for doing real conversation
i know you have your own opinions here
but this is some of the truest
journalism type stuff we have
absolutely yeah i i mean hopefully
you know you got to say everything you
wanted to say so far and telling your
story and everything like that and
people can understand what's happening
chris debaun says tim you are wrong
about seceding west and northeast coast
states
with disproportionate control house all
com institutions and corporations
allowing ccp infection to spread
infection is too bad we must amputate i
you know i i mentioned this in my main
segment today about uh biden issuing
sanctions on china
i'm happy that he's doing something
hopefully it's enough i don't know if it
will be
but i think if the u.s breaks apart
china wins and they're authoritarians
and they got concentration camps and
that's gonna be a nightmare for the rest
of the world so i'm not a fan of that
i got criticism for biden but if he does
something that's good i'm not gonna rag
on him for i'm gonna give him credit
where credit is due
memo type says sup tim ian lydia heart
the show just joined on the members page
and love the ufo talk with chrissy
if you're into that stuff look at
missing 4-1-1
researched by former detective david
paulides ongoing thing with people going
missing very mysterious ooh i will check
that out that's very fun
thank you cousin william says a wrap is
no more than a chant and has been going
on in every culture forever and a day
yeah not anymore and now it's racist
it's like vocal drum beats with language
oh yeah
william martin says hey tim with gun
control back in full swing
have you thought about having colin noir
uh
or someone like that or something like
that on the show also have you ever
looked into john lavelle from the
warrior poet society network
i think they would both be great guests
uh yeah we'd love to have colleen noire
on um
i wonder why we have it maybe we should
need to reach out to him maybe he's not
available i don't know we'll figure it
out
he's busy he's busy there you go he's
super busy yeah yeah he has like an open
invitation we're gonna make it happen
all right let's see shane kerwood says
let's set her up y'all
f smith wish i could give more but still
got bills to pay
well yes there's a there's a gofundme
for uh
wha what's the title of the video for me
it's help jody shaw with
legal and living expenses just google
jody sean gofundme you'll find it
if you thank you thank you eve thank you
so much
jp2543 says started watching daily after
crowder's election stream
you crowder shapiro and bongino are who
i listen to daily
just joined tim cass today you need to
have jp sears awaken with jp or colleen
noir
they're both very busy one of the
biggest challenges
with uh people who have their own shows
is they have their own shows they don't
need to come on this show i mean it
would be great for us but you know
they're doing their thing
and i love i love the idea it's like
watching me crowder shapiro and bongino
i'm pretty sure i have very different
opinions from like the three of those
and i think
crowd shaping and bengino have similar
opinions but i think that's the
important thing that's that's fantastic
it's funny when they try and claim i'm a
conservative and it's like they watch
the show and tim poole rags about how
like
the wheat attacks the rich or something
it's like pretty sure that's not a
conservative opinion would you say how
the weed attacks the risks how we need
to tax the rich
i would love to see you on with crowder
yeah what i've been on credit several
times
all-star yeah and it's funny because
he's like you know tim pool you love him
or you hate him
and i'm like well that's fair i think
crowd was great
yeah uh i think he's made some really
offensive comedy
but it's weird how like you know media
matters went after him because he did
this segment they called really racist
and i'm like what was the difference
between what he did and what family guy
does literally every single day when i
watch family guy
like free pass family guys jokes are
are ten times more racist than anything
crowd has ever done and they're just
jokes they're like you they people poke
the bear they try to be offensive for
like
you know whatever but it's political
that's why it's cause crowder does
political commentary and that's an issue
for them
stephen decker says what you're doing is
awesome jody is there anyone working on
behalf of the security
security guard and custodians who had
their lives ruined the
that crazy word i can't say on tim cast
woman who started this
should be sued to oblivion yes actually
very exciting the woodson center bob
woodson
is a civil rights era civil rights
leader he marched
for civil rights for the civil rights
act of 1964 and he
uh just sent a letter to president
kathleen mccartney she's the president
of smith college signed by 44 black
intellectuals and leaders from across
the country asking her to
stop the crt stuff uh make apologize
publicly to these employees that have
been hurt and to make them whole
and so um and he he also in the letter
asked
they also asked her to provide evidence
because she's claiming that
uh in response to the new york times
there's a new york times article she's
claiming
that she there's a reason why we have to
keep doing this
these racial justice initiatives and she
named all these racial disparities
and so bob woods in his letter said okay
what you're talking about where's the
evidence
we would like to see some evidence so
i'm waiting to see how she's going to
respond to this letter if she's going to
respond to it um
those who demand evidence are just white
supremacists trying to protect
themselves
that's your proof well that's the
problem right it's an attack on it's an
attack on evidence yes also they don't
believe in evidence the word
this is
yeah he said that actually to me he's
like this is a perversion
of civil justice of civil rights that's
what he said a perversion
yeah cine castro says have you guys
considered having dennis prager on um
yeah i'd love to have dennis prager on
but he seems like a bit of a big fish
there are a lot of people i'd love to
have on the show as well but like
the most prominent figures in politics
hey man
they're welcome donald trump how about
him too come on over
he did he did uh lisa booth's podcast he
emailed me about it and i was like wow
that's really great good for her that's
awesome that's it that's it
hopefully it was a good interview i'd
love to interview trump because it'd be
a really weird interview but i get mad
at me
i'm like i voted for you but here are
the things i i'm mad about
i'd have to give him a compliment
sandwich where i'm like i know the media
is lying about so much
i like this stuff now here's the things
i don't like dude but don't forget i do
like this one he's so
candid like i want to get him just
chilling like the three of like just
hang out for a minute so people can see
who you really are dude
just relax it's having fun yeah like i
just enjoyed that rogan
yeah like donald trump on rogan would
have been one of the best yeah he still
still will be maybe now is the right
time for for joe to have him on
i wonder if you would actually do it
though i think trump doesn't care man
all right nadia shall worry no more says
my siblings and i are all mexican but
only i look it
my bro was talking to his latino friend
jokingly calling each other
i'll just say offensive where i don't
know if youtube allows me to say that a
girl told me
the uh a girl told the admin my bro was
white
saying it he tried to explain but
edmonds and my brother doesn't look it
so stop
whoa yeah i don't know how these how the
rules work whatever
you just can't do it if you're not in
the tribe if you're in the tribe you get
away with whatever you want whatever you
want
mason wolfie says maybe instead of race
and skin color we should start pushing
for calling each other americans
hear hear good sir wow yeah i like that
but don't get too hung up on it because
it's still a label
it's still an identity politic thing
christopher o'reilly says hey tim
you should read the 5 000 year leap by
cleon skusen then talk about it
first time giving please read also love
from wisconsin
right on we'll check it out that was
nearly interesting
all right let's see keep with the good
work appreciate the super chat
slanty chauffeur bear says when you look
at original pre uh
original print pre-1900 1950s books
you'll find the dark age is described as
everything bc before christ the
enlightenment the age of reason
was is everything a d n o domini
interesting i didn't know that john
baloo says there was a comedian in the
early 90s that said
the only people you can make fun of is
white protestant males
because they're the only ones that don't
have a group to come after you so true
today
i mean they they do and what
what was the clan were they catholic or
what was their religion i don't know if
they're protestant
were they protestant i don't know
probably all right let's see
divisive software says
hey tim love the show probably a faux
pas but yesterday a dude shouted out his
podcast in super chat thought i'd try
i put a game on steam three years ago
called
uh hole and glide is that what says
holland glide i've only sold 22 copies
oh well you could revive it sorry if
this is cringe really love the show
thanks
not cringe dude that was awesome i'm
gonna i want to try it what's it
how do you spell it h-o-l-o-n-g-l-i-d-e
that's right right yeah
pull-and-glide what's the game like i'm
interested
i'm always looking for new games because
i get really bored of games real quick
yeah i got like 800 games on steam
i just play skater xl now just a
skateboarding game and just dude
playing caves like crude lately caves of
quad i don't know how to pronounce
why don't you play holland glide check
it out yeah
he only sold 22 copies maybe he'll sell
them more but it better be a good game
i need quality if if i could read every
super chat then people would
get shout outs all the time but we don't
want good money
gerg c says razer fist ask him on yeah
i'd love to have razer faces cool
loud all right let's see andrew matina
says jody not to mention names but years
back you were booked at a music festival
i spearheaded in upstate new york
love your music and i love your cause
and you swim pretty good too
is all of that is all that true yes it
is cool
who is that andrew mattina
oh thanks andrew you were booked to the
show
yeah do you play instruments yes i do
which ones
i play piano and guitar and i sing and i
just learned how to play drums
she rapped earlier which she did it was
cool never buddy i enjoyed him
nice talent
all right mr big says tim nobody views
themselves as the villain
some of history's worst leaders saw
themselves as liberators and saviors
that's absolutely true yeah
all right let's see ian tifa oh i've
heard it before
ent
that was funny
oh okay let's see how clever the first
okay someone someone says the clan was
massively anti-catholic okay i knew
catholic was related to them somewhere
i got it way wrong though so i apologize
booker dewitt catch says daniel
uh dana lash she is she is you you need
um she is you need on your show who you
need on the show
sometimes people typo um again big
but she is a media personality and very
busy
i'm sure she would if she was not got
her own massive platform that's the
thing right
somebody who's got their own massive
multi-million subscriber follower
platform doesn't need to go on someone's
show
unless they just want to do it for fun
but uh i'd love to have dana lash
she's great it'd be really great
conversation about guns because
uh the more i buy guns and read into
them and learn about them the more i'm
confused by what i'm hearing from the
from politics like there was one post
from guy adam best and he like named
all of these you know tragic incidents
he's like ar-15 ar-15 ar-15 over and
over again
and i'm like what what though
like an air 15 years like it's like him
saying gun gun
a gun was used here and a gun was used
here and i'm like air 15 what
there's like so many different variants
you're just saying gun over and over it
doesn't mean anything
they don't know what they're talking
about anyway chase says i am suing my
former job
i was called the white supremacist after
expressing anti-work commentary online i
was forced into weekly one-on-one
anti-racism training for months before i
had to quit
but i didn't bend the knee bravo that's
awesome good for you
good for you um feel free to reach out
to me if you want
yeah it just says chase but uh is there
a way people can reach out to you
yeah it's my i have a jodyshaw.net
there's a contact button you can contact
me
mr paul r says if jody shaw lost friends
they're not friends yes
that's true yeah it feels like a friend
is gonna have your back
no matter what yep even if i always
agree with you and sometimes they leave
and then they come back
and you're in the middle of it right now
casey finnegan says hey tim
did you hear that rebel news was
demonetized today when ezra levant asked
why
the youtube rep said she would check
with her team the woke is coming for
everyone that's why i joined your site
thank you
this is why we should have set up
timcast.com a long time ago last year
when we started
the tim castro podcast we should have
set up a website we didn't
we did recently because the purge is
real and they're gonna
demonetize purge and a lot of people i
love it when they're like tim pool's
never getting burned he stole milk toast
my facebook page has already been
demonetized and
booted off i can't it's over you can't
spill d monetize without demon
there you go it's a good point for toast
milk toast yeah yeah so the joke is tim
pool's a milk toast
sitter and it's m-i-l-q-u-e it's you
know you know milk does right yeah i
know
but no just like kind of shocked that it
was used in conjunction with you
it's a joke because i'm not i'm centrist
did you make milk toast
in the beginning whenever a little bit
that's a weird thing that's a real
breakfast i guess
yeah my grandma used to milk a toast or
milk toast yeah it's gross and weird
i recommend it so uh
it's a joke obviously you know i can't
remember who on the show but they were
like why are they allowing you to do
this and i'm like who's there like the
establishment you know like the
democrats and the media and like
why aren't they like smearing you more
and like trying to get you banned or
whatever and i'm like i don't know
you know because you know but but they
what they basically said was
it's not that you're you know
right wing or left wing or whatever it's
that you're exposing how they operate
and i was like yeah well you know there
you go so yeah anyway join timcast.com
become a member
because that's the safety net if if we
get shut down
the show's over like we can still work
so long as timcast.com exists
and that's why i'm trying to get the new
site where
we're gonna launch a brand site which is
gonna do way more content articles
news and all that stuff and everything
and video games and
skateboarding and stuff because we need
to build something independent so we
can't get shut down
although we'll see what happens youtube
implemented this new thing
where it like when you upload a video it
runs a percentage check like scanning
your content for negative words
and so demonetization has started
hitting me again for a while i wasn't
getting hit
so we'll see what happens but i will say
timcast.com is offsetting the loss of
youtube ad revenue which i'm not super
concerned about at this point
charles belo uh balozian says
talking with woke liberals can be fun
especially when i remind them of my
grandparents literally
literally survived actual genocide and
religious persecution
good times but it's like they don't care
you know you know
it's like when you actually explain to
one of these white woke progressives
when i've tried telling them oh okay so
your logic applies to me as a mixed-race
person i'll
say no no you don't count like i get to
say that i'm
it's like what but you're the white
person you're supposed to be the racist
by your own logic
i don't work that way uh
cause castellano says there are chickens
that lay different color eggs
blue green pink dark chocolate brown et
cetera two true colors white and blue
blue is because of a virus that changes
the shell color check it out really
yeah because we have chickens we were
given
a sampler that's what the guy called it
and he was like you'll have all
different colored eggs
i'm excited so cool yeah they are all
easter eggs
kim hansen says tim every once in a
while give politics a rest since you are
a musician i suggest a great cover band
called foxes and fossils they have a
youtube channel give it a listen
get them on the show you won't be
disappointed well we have a venue
and we're planning on doing live events
very soon if the weather is improving
we're going to have like a limited
limited availability for members only
tickets
that uh you can buy and come to the
actual studio for a night
of you know barbecue on the grill
and musicians and comedians and uh we're
we're planning this out we want to get
some pretty pretty good bands
and uh uh commentators you know it'll be
really great to get some of these more
political commentators who do kind of a
comedy routine
get them up on stage andrew doyle and
we're oh definitely
yeah he's great but he's he's locked in
the uk isn't he
we'll get him as soon as he's not is he
yeah you can't leave the ufc if you try
to leave
they find you but i think you can travel
for work so if they want to they can
still
for work leave and uh so that might work
but yeah andrew doyle
dankula count dankula is is an amazing
stage
presence too he's really really great it
would be it would be so fun
to have him and obviously carl benjamin
and do a big thing
i want to hear what you guys think about
us bringing back jam night on fridays if
you like that idea
i like that idea i i heard about it why
did it stop
when adam left we just forced it to
happen basically and i'm bringing it
back
well the show the show changed we
started doing more uh
guests and then yeah but now
now we're once we we haven't yet
completely set up all the infrastructure
of the venue i call it the garage
because of the weather now that it's
finally breaking into the 60s
we can start setting up the computer the
lights the drums i want to play so much
because i'm up like a kind of a
political idiot
and so when we talk politics i'm like oh
just stay cool man wait for your moment
but when
when we rock i can hit it hard you know
i'm ready
all right let's see bobby digital says
i'm subscribed at timcast.com can you
pretty please make videos downloadable
and pocket listenable i
don't know how to do that right now but
um we have
a new website that's about to launch and
it's going to create new
subscriber options through different you
know um
new subscriber weapons just because
right now it's just basically paypal but
we're going to be opening up for
it's just improving basically we built
what we could build
build initially when everyone became
members
then we basically used that all those
resources to start
hiring a new dev team and expanding and
we want to we want to build
open source uh social networking code
that anyone could put onto their website
so you mentioned you had what
jodyshaw.net
how cool would it be if we had an open
source plugin that you put on your
website and it was a social media app
that networked you to every other
website that used the same app
that way no one could ban you it's just
your website and but people on your
website could interact with people on
other websites too
oh i see so the the social media app is
like embedded it's like
not out there but it would basically be
the fetiverse
you know which would the fetiverse
betaverse is a decentralized twitter
where different servers can interact
with each other like peer-to-peer
yeah yeah kind of thing like a browser
so it could you could basically
be like create a user account if they're
a member of your website
then their username could be like bill
jodyshaw.net
and when they post people can choose to
follow bill jodyshaw.net
kind of like gaps people would see gab
too because gab i believe is on the
fetaverse so
you could be bill gabb.com and people
could on your website could follow
people on gap
wow about to happen really
we want to get there but we're small and
we're growing and we can't just snap our
fingers and instantly be 100 companies
yeah it's like a community project which
is the nice thing about it being open
source too is contributors from around
the world will go on github and git lab
and
be like suppositing code for others to
use free software actually so like a
mit license or something all right we
got political pothead he says
shout out to rappers tom mcdonald up
church and adam calhoun they're building
culture
there is a whole pool of independent
rappers not muzzled by record labels
and surprise they're not woke yup i love
the independence yeah
oh hey okay uh kaleb caleb w says got my
diamond hands gorilla t-shirt today
check out dax's new video my friends
make sure you get your diamond hands
gorilla shirt
go to cast.com i got mine yeah joey's
got some i got one here but it's a
misprint
you bust it out yeah yeah yeah it has
one so it's good
they uh his eyes are blue i guess and
his it's just too dark
too dark yeah it's too dark but uh uh
i i i i'm a bit reluctant to show the
misprint one because
before we before this got sent to us
teespring
emailed me and said you're gonna be
getting double your order
because the first shirts that went out
were printed too dark and so we're
sending you double the order so you're
getting like
two for the price of one and i was like
cool so
they they've been taking care of me much
respect there was a big fiasco that
happened with the gorilla shirts with
them a while ago but they they did right
by us and i think i think they do great
their shirts are amazing quality by the
way the misprints could be a collector's
item yeah
they are these i was thinking yeah so we
gave some of them away but i think
these particular ones are not offensive
miss prince like the other ones were
that almost got us in trouble yeah they
were a little low but uh
we might see it we'll we'll give we'll
give some of these out we'll sign them
and stuff like that
and uh yeah yeah the other one was
hilariously all right here we go
mannian lee says i think candace owens
is one of the most powerful weapons we
have against the woke
do you think she would make a good
presidential candidate for 2024
maybe not 2024 um maybe later on
she is a good uh i would agree
well i would say this i think she is a
good weapon against the woke however
she's also called for imprisoning people
for burning the flag and that's not
gonna jive with liberals
uh look i'm not talking about woke
insanity
i'm talking about regular freedom-loving
social and classical liberals who are
like look man i don't agree with burning
the flag but if it's your flag
do what you want with it that's your
speech it's the george carlin type
liberals that you
you are like the conservatives have won
over a lot of aspects threatening to
imprison people from burning a flag
you're going to lose all of them quick
i don't know what your thoughts would
you agree on that one would you do you
think burning the flag should be allowed
oh gosh i haven't thought about it but
i'm just thinking about like i don't
know that that's
a reason to write somebody off just
because they have that
belief because they think you should be
arrested for burning the flag or because
they believe in burning the flag well
they probably maybe they shouldn't be
president if they
trump the same thing trump said you
should get a year in jail so
i'll tell you this that's why i'm saying
she's a good you know
uh she's a good personality challenging
wokeness i'm not discrediting everything
she said because she holds one
one opinion i disagree with i just think
that's going to cost her a lot of
liberal support
yeah people as well way of changing
their mind their mind on
topics when they run for pr and uh
issues when they run for president
i think people who burn the flag should
get a stern finger wagging yeah and if
it's your flag
well i guess you burn what you want man
you know it's like i i i would never
burn the flag
i love the american flag i think this
country is fantastic because i've
traveled the world
but penn teller did this really amazing
bit they have this really amazing bit
where they do a magic trick where they
it's a magic trick they don't really
burn the flag but they do and it like
goes up in flames
and pen says burning the flag is the
ultimate
ultimate expression of the freedom that
it represents and i'm like
it's paradoxical but when i see these
like
antifa and leftist types like burning
the flag because i hate america
they're only proving how awesome this
country really is yeah that's
good that's a good point that's that's
one of our freedoms right
yeah there's countries where they'll
execute you for doing that in america
you'll get a finger wagging maybe you
know yeah maybe
you'll get people yelling at you and
trying to take it from you to stop you
from burning it maybe
but like in in thailand insulting the
royal family you go to jail yeah just
words alone can get you
yeah shadow cloud says i'd love to come
by the van and play some magic the
gathering when you guys are in nashville
oh it's not a van
it's a 40-foot trailer it's not like a
full
it's gonna be a full studio setup and uh
i don't it's gonna be a very very
arduous task doing a road trip it's
gonna not gonna be an easy thing to do
so i don't know how much time we'll have
no magic games i don't know about
playing imagine the gathering
when we're like working for a week
straight on tour it's gonna be stressful
people are gonna lose their minds they
don't people
any like people who have never been on a
tour don't don't get it
somebody somebody mentioned something uh
rr says jody's music is on itunes
that's true how do they find it jody
shaw j-o-d-i
it's on band camp too and you have like
super amazing top 40 hits that everyone
will
listen to in the end you'll just become
a famous musician
there you go perfect i like that i like
that prediction
let's go with it waffles sensei says tim
i can't
i can't wait to see your take on the
speech biden gave in colorado oh boy
he's coming for your assault rifles
whatever that means he also has a moment
that he says not until i have
all the facts about the shooter it gets
obnoxious at this point bro
yeah uh assault rifles what you mean
like nfa items that cost like 30 grand
that very few people have
so assault rifle references select fire
rifles so they're full auto
full auto burst or or semi yeah those
are extremely expensive
they're already ridiculously hard to get
whatever you can get gatling guns though
because those are like
i guess each each like crank or whatever
is a single action so you're allowed to
have a leakage but it doesn't do like 60
cranks a second
or something that'll spin so fast but
could you go super fast with your hand
like ch
ch yeah definitely luke wanted me to buy
a gatling gun a nine millimeter
hundred it was like a massive magazine
thing on the side and you hold it go
down
and i'm like what am i going to do with
that it's on wheels i'm like shooting
he's like i'm just telling you man you
know you got to buy it now before it's
illegal
i'm like all right i'm not buying
gatling gun luke come on
he has convinced me to buy some dumb
things though i wonder where that guy
went huh
like the sword like the lightsaber thing
that you were talking about that was all
tim
oh like the little torch thing i saw
that on instagram yeah all right ottie
cosmo says have lauren southern on
had a great video a month ago uh feeling
don't care about your facts
that's actually something i said on
twitter quite a while ago when when ben
shapiro said facts don't care about your
feelings
i tweeted feelings don't care about your
facts because both are true
feelings don't care about your facts and
that's why a lot of people driven by
feelings don't care about
objective reality uh as for lauren she's
in australia
oh wow is that where she lives i believe
she lives in australia now right
she does yeah yeah so uh i'd love to
have lawrence other on but
yeah i want to hear her her personal
like perception of her story for the
last
four or five years because she was like
came out of obscurity and was super
famous for a short period of time and
kind of got burned by like
the cancel culture well she got into
trouble for like
being on the ocean and and bunch of
stuff yeah i want to hear all her
personal like what she
thinks about it well my friends is what
you need to do
i want her on you need to go to
timcast.com and become a member because
the purge is real we just heard rebel
news
you know they got demonetized who knows
how long until they come for us as well
so we need
your membership to keep doing the work
or i should say it's the safety net in
the event we do get banned
and uh timcast.com is gonna become the
real
uh bread and butter i guess that's
that's what we're focusing on building
our own sustainable platform that can't
be banned and a larger brand to
encompass it
that way it'll exist beyond just like a
youtube channel so we're getting there
but go there now because we're gonna
have an exclusive members only segment
probably with a lot more profanity we
always say that there usually is so
that'll be up and you can check it out
again timcast.com
but uh don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe hit the notification
bell and if you really like the show
share it it's the best thing you can do
because that's what actually drives
you know growth i suppose you can follow
me on all podcasts
you can follow me on all social media
platforms at tim cast
and you can check out my other youtube
channels youtube.comtimcast and
youtube.comtimcast2 this
you youtube.comcastnews we got this
i'm trying you're animal all right this
show is live monday the friday at 8pm so
we
will obviously be back tomorrow but uh
jody is there anything you want to shout
out social media or
gofundme or something oh yeah
jodyshaw.net
for supporting me in this fight and
jodyshaw.com if you want to check out my
music oh cool
and um there might be some gofundme
comings i'm working on it
go fund me coming gofundme's coming
for the staff who were impacted by the
july 31 2018
incident so very cool i'll keep you
posted
oh you guys can follow me in
crossland.net uh you can see all my
socials from there and keep in touch
that way thank you for coming
you guys can follow me at real sour
patch lids on twitter and mines
and if you guys like you are more than
welcome to tune in to my instagram
because every night after the show i
basically kind of talk about what we
talked about on the show and give my own
personal thoughts and feelings so i'm
able to condense them and get them a
little more a little less wordy i should
say
we will see you all over in the
exclusive members only segment at
timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you